Rechner anmachen. Und irgendwie bin ich leiser. Oder? Ach nee. WTF. So. Was ist das? Bildkontakte.
Richtig. Ja. Ok. Was auch immer. Ich muss mal einen Vorschaurechner anmachen, weil ich
sehe weder Chat noch sonst irgendwas. Vielleicht. Es ist eh noch keiner da. Das ist ja ok. Dann
ist ja gut. Irgendwie habe ich das Problem, dass auf der linken Seite mein Headset lauter
ist als auf der rechten. Ich glaube das ist nicht richtig angeschlossen. Oder der Wackelkontakt
von meinem komischen Mute-Button hat wieder zugeschlagen. Ich habe hier so einen Mute-Button
zwischen Mikrofon und Audio-Interface. Kann ich im Zweifelsfall so draufhauen. Ich zeige
es mal so. Gleich bin ich weg. Blablabla. Mute-Button. Also wenn irgendwie was ist. Keine Ahnung
wenn DHL an der Tür klingelt oder so. Dann muss ich nicht lange rumfodeln. Irgendwo
etwas anklicken oder so. Sondern BÄM einfach Mute-Button. Face. Face. Ah ja. Ok. Nice.
Also erstmal muss ich mein Meme-Tool starten. Ohne geht ja nichts. Der ist ausgeschlossen.
Achso. Gehen eigentlich die Donations wieder? Gehen die Donations wieder? Ne. Grip-Donations.
Vielleicht muss man Tippy-Stream jetzt bezahlen oder so. Keine Ahnung. Aber das sehe ich
nicht ein. Die kriegen ja schon was von den Donations ab. Warum sollte man da was extra
bezahlen für eine Alert-Box? Eine Alert-Box ist ja die Fall-Dra eigentlich. Naja. Was
auch immer. Easy. Ja irgendwie ist links und rechts mein Headset unterschiedlich laut.
Da habe ich zu viel reingehustet gerade. Man weiß es nicht. Man weiß es nicht. Komisch
auf jeden Fall. Hier Leute guckt mal was ich gelesen habe vorhin. Am Montag 19. Ne.
Moment. Wann geht das los? Also keine Ahnung ob da was dran ist. Müssen wir mal suchen.
Das wäre mal ein Grund die PS4 wieder anzuwerfen. Keine Ahnung ob da was dran ist. Also das
kann genauso gut Fake sein. Man weiß es nicht. Es ist immer schwer zu sagen. Aber sollte
das stimmen, dass es dann am 19. Es kann ja auch sein. Genau die Announcen das am Montag
und dann kann man am 22. August spielen. Das wäre ja irgendwie relativ sinnvoll. Ja. Also
mal angenommen das stimmt. Ich schreibe schon Alpha. Das ist ja nicht offiziell. Das ist
ja null offiziell. Gar nichts offizielles. Irgendwie können die krassen Chillstepper
sich nicht überlegen wie laut ihre Musik sein soll. Jetzt lauter. Die wissen es nicht
genau. Ich meine wenn man so eine Compilation hoch lädt. Wenn man so eine Compilation hoch
lädt könnte man doch wenigstens dafür sorgen, dass der Sound überall gleich laut ist. Das
ist doch das Mindeste was man machen kann, wenn man hier schon die Musikstücke wahrscheinlich
zusammen klaut. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass du eine PS4. Ich habe eine PS4 Site Release.
Ich habe auch eine Xbox One Site Release. Das ist aber komplett useless, weil ich sie nicht
benutze. Naja. Zumindest wenn das der Fall ist, wenn das hier stimmt, dann werden wir
wahrscheinlich nächste Woche auf der PS4 ein bisschen MW4 spielen. Ich nenne es am liebsten
MW4, weil ich absolut verwirrt bin, wenn man einfach nur Modern Warfare oder MW sagt.
Jetzt müssen wir mal ausprobieren. Die Sache ist ja die. Ich habe zwei linke Hände am PS4
Controller. Xbox Controller kein Problem. PS4 Controller kriege ich nicht gebacken.
Generell ist der Playstation Controller zu klein und zu wackelig. Da passt es nicht
mein Fall. Ich habe einen Adapter, wo man einen Xbox Controller an die Playstation 4 anschließen
kann. Das ist ok. Oder aber, was ich mir überlegt habe, was ich mal ausprobieren kann, wobei
ich nicht weiß, ob das nicht schon als Cheaten gilt. Ich habe mir vor einem Jahr oder so
mal sowas hier gekauft. Als ich mir gedacht habe, willst du mal ausprobieren oder probierst
mal Maus an der Konsole aus, wie die Dinger so sind. Ich habe es aber nie ausprobiert.
Es bewegt hier immer noch rum und zwar ist das so ein Teil. Das macht Mausemulation auf
der, also das tut so als wäre es ein Controller und man kann eine Maus anschließen. Das wird
natürlich nicht richtig gut funktionieren, weil ein Analogstick ein komplett anderes
Input Medium ist als eine Maus. Einen Analogstick, den hältst du gedrückt und dann bewegt sich
es weiter und eine Maus bewegt sich nur, wie lange du die Maus bewegst. Keine Ahnung,
wie gut das ist. Ich weiß noch nicht, zählt das als Cheaten sowas? Ist da Monkathos angesagt,
was man damit spielt oder? Ja. Also ich glaube nicht, dass man dafür gebannt wird. Ah, it's
not cheating. Sagt er, ja. Wenn die Battlefield Dudes sagen, es ist not cheating, dann ist
das not cheating. Ich meine, aus meiner Sicht, ehrlich gesagt, ist es cheating. Und ganz
davon abgesehen, die werden dich nicht dafür bannen. Es ist schon beschiss, wenn es gut
funktioniert. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob es gut funktioniert. Also ich habe keine Ahnung,
was in Fortnite wirst du gebannt damit? Echt jetzt? Oder was meint der Herz93? Also ich
finde schon, dass es cheating ist. Wenn es gut funktioniert, ich habe keine Ahnung, ob
es gut funktioniert. Ich hatte mir das Ding vor 2 Jahren oder 1,5 Jahren gekauft, falls
ich mal wieder PS4 spielen will und keinen Bock habe auf PS4 Controller. Was kostet
der Kram eigentlich mittlerweile? Alter! IOS? Onks? IOS? Was hat es mit IOS zu tun? Wahrscheinlich
ist schon ein echt krasser Preis für sowas. Von Prime-Sub auf Stufe 1 gewechselt. Poggers,
ich habe aber keine Ahnung, ich habe keinen Sound bekommen, das du gesubbt hast. Ist das
kaputt? Any primers in chat? Ich habe keine Ahnung, ist das kaputt? Ich muss mal kurz
einen Test-Sub machen. Streamlabs, mal einen Test-Sub. Warte mal, naja, nicht go to dashboard.
Alertbox, Test-Sub? Nö. Keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht. Zumindest, ach, weil schon Prime-Sub
vorher war, aber Erneuerungen kriegst du ja auch hin. Erneuerungen kriegt man eigentlich
auch mit. Keine Ahnung, was das für was das ist. Egal, alles, alles, alles Pog. Es könnte
sein, dass das erste Resub erst kommt, wenn der Prime-Sub ausgelaufen ist. Da gehe ich
mal von aus. Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass, weil ich habe das seit ungefähr, muss mal
zurückscrollen, ab wann bin ich Partner? Seit, seit neunzehnten, also morgen, morgen laufen
die Subs aus. Also dann werde ich sehen, wahrscheinlich kommt dann morgen der Resub-Sound, vermute
ich mal. Naja, zumindest, wenn das hier stimmt, dass die eine Open Gunfight Alpha starten
nächstes Wochenende, dann probieren wir das auf der PS4 mal aus. Dann werde ich auch mal
dieses Ding hier ausprobieren, was ich vor ein paar Jahren, vor eineinhalb Jahren gekauft
habe, für Maus an PS4 und so tun, als wäre es ein Controller. Wie gesagt, also aus dem
Bauch raus würde ich sagen, es ist schon eine Art von Cheaten. Anders kann man es eigentlich
nicht sagen, wenn man mit Maus gegen Controller spielt, immer unter der Voraussetzung, es
funktioniert ordentlich. Wenn das nicht ordentlich funktioniert, dann ist es natürlich auch kein
Vorteil irgendwo. Man kann zwar cheaten, aber solange es keinen Vorteil bringt, ist die Sache
irgendwie ziemlich beknackt. Das geht angeblich überall, sagen sie. Xbox One, PS4, 360 und
PS3, die Dinger gibt es auch schon eine Weile. Ich habe mir ja mal so ein Ding da gekauft,
so was da, um den, damit man die Controller überall anschließen kann. Das ist eigentlich
auch ganz cool, also da kannst du alle Controller überall anschließen. Das ist ganz praktisch,
allerdings ist die Maus-Emulation da kürze, das hatte ich schon mal ausprobiert, schon
eine ganze Weile her bei, keine Ahnung, bei Advanced Warfare oder sowas. Und das hier soll
die beste Maus-Emulation auf der Playstation sein. Naja, mal gucken, wie gut das funktioniert.
Warum hat Twitch noch keine Notification gesendet? Ich weiß nicht, wir gucken mal,
ob Discord, ob Discord gesendet hat. Gucken wir mal, Discord hat. Makros gehen mit dem
Ding auch, ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, ob damit, ich habe mir das noch gar
nicht so genau angeschaut. Ja, tatsächlich, Discord, Discord hat, hat geschickt. Ich weiß
nicht, gehen damit Makros, Makros, Makro, keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich, im Zweifelsfall
gehen damit auch Makros. Da kannst du natürlich dann besonders, besonders nice irgendwelche
Scripts ausführen, dass du dann beispielsweise, wenn es wieder so eine, sollte es wieder
so eine Mechanik geben, wie beispielsweise in Bad Company 2, wo du Shotgun reloaden,
Waffen switchen kannst, würde ich das dann automatisch als Makro hinlegen. Weil wenn
schon Hacksorn dann richtig. Ne, also mal gucken, was das taucht. Ich bin da ein bisschen,
naja, das habe ich im Hals. Ich bin da ein bisschen Zwiegespalten, weil auf der einen
Seite ist, wenn das gut funktioniert, ist es eindeutig Cheaten oder zumindest, nicht
wirklich Cheaten, du manipulierst ja nicht irgendwie das Game oder so, aber sag mal mal,
Pay to Win ist es im Endeffekt, wenn das gut funktioniert. Also Vorteil verschaffen mit
Sachen, die andere nicht haben und nicht bekommen können, außer sie investieren nochmal extra
Geld. Auf der anderen Seite, ich kann mit dem PS4 Controller nicht spielen. Ich krieg's
überhaupt nicht gebacken. Allein schon, wenn ich den DualShock in die Hand nehme. Das fühlt
sich, ich verkrampfe da übelst mit den Händen, weil ich die ganze Zeit da war und mich unten
festhalten. Xbox Controller kannst du ruhig in der Hand liegen lassen, überhaupt kein
Problem. Egal, probieren wir dann. Sollte wirklich jetzt hier, sollte da stimmen, was
der Statut gepostet hat, dass die Open Alpha, dass es eine Open Alpha nächstes Wochenende
gibt, die morgen angekündigt wird. Ich mein, es würde passen, ja, es würde passen, weil
morgen ist Gamescom Eröffnung, also ne, Gamescom Pressekonferenz Tag, das streamen wir morgen
ja auch und Activision kommt ja auf diese komische, diese Gamescom Night und da könnt
ich mir gut vorstellen, dass sie das in der Hinterhand haben und sagen, hey Leute, nächstes
Wochenende gibt es den Modern Warfare MW4 Gunfight Mode Open Alpha auf der PS4. Wobei
ich sagen muss, der Typ hat echt recht, ne, das geht mir echt auf den Sack. Das geht mir
bei allen Sachen auf den Kicks, also natürlich nur bei Spielen, die ich spielen will, diese
Exklusivitätskacke, ich mein, was ist denn, was ist denn dann, was kommt denn da am Ende
wieder raus, dass es auf dem PC kacke läuft wahrscheinlich. Das ist wahrscheinlich auf
dem PC wieder ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, 2080 Extreme RTX, TI, sonst was brauchst, dass
es mit, mit 70 Frames läuft, also. Mit dem Xim kann man easy ein Yitter Mod spielen,
in short, was total übertrieben ist. Was ist denn ein Yitter Mod? Ist das, dass man Single
Mods automatisch macht, oder wie? Ich kann mir da nix drunter vorstellen gerade. Ich hab
keine Ahnung, was ein Yitter, ich will jetzt auch nicht danach suchen, weil das wahrscheinlich
Monkathos ist, wenn man so Zeug zeigt im Stream. Keine Ahnung, was das ist. Moinshinkuru, Aim
mit Maus, naja, richtig. Es wird alles gecancelt, was geht, man macht aus einer Shotgun eine
Rapid Fire Gun. Hä? Also, ja gut, aber wenn alles gecancelt wird, kann man es doch auch
mit dem Controller machen, oder? Oder braucht man einfach, bräuchte man einfach 20 Finger,
um es mit dem Controller zu machen, und deswegen geht es nicht. Wahrscheinlich. Wahrscheinlich
müsste es zu schnell sein, und man braucht 20 Finger für den Controller. Ja. Na ja,
mal gucken, ob wir das ausprobieren. Es ist so Grauzonen-Cheating. Es ist kein offizielles
Cheating, aber es ist eindeutig Cheating in Form von, man verschafft sich Vorteile gegenüber
anderen Leuten. Yitter, kenn ich nur von Netzwerken. Ja, ich auch. Ich auch. Aber das ist der Next-Level-Cheating.
Ich probiere es, ich werde es nächste Woche mal ausprobieren. Ich habe mir das Ding eh
schon vor eineinhalb Jahren gekauft. Also einfach mal anschließen und gucken werde
ich es machen, und für eine Beta ist es jetzt nicht so wild. Wenn dann das Game richtig
rauskommt, werde ich es auf jeden Fall auf dem PC spielen. Vielleicht spiele ich es
auch einfach, ich werde es mal ausprobieren. Ich werde es mit dem Xbox-Controller mal probieren
und mal mit dieser Maus-Emulation mal gucken, wie gut das funktioniert. Zählt es auch als
Cheating, wenn einer mit 30 FPS spielt, der andere mit 144 FPS? Das würde es zählen,
wenn die Plattform das vorschreiben würde, was ja nicht so ist. Also wenn du jetzt eine
Plattform, also mal angenommen, du hättest eine PS4, die es mit 30 FPS spielt und die
PS4 Pro würde es mit 144 FPS spielen, dann wäre das auch so eine Art von Pay to Win
irgendwie. Aber ich weiß gar nicht, wie groß die grafischen Unterschiede sind zwischen
der normalen PS4. Wie war das denn bei Black Ops 4? PS4 vs. Pro. War da ein großer Unterschied?
Es sieht ein bisschen schärfer aus, ja. Es sieht ein bisschen schärfer aus. Alter mach
doch mal den Kram weg. Es sieht ein bisschen schärfer aus rechts und die Frame Rate scheint
ein minimal konstanter zu sein, aber so großartige Unterschiede ist es jetzt auch nicht. Ich
finde links, das Video sieht einfach aus, als wäre es mit schlechterer Bitrate aufgenommen.
Weil ich habe ja nur eine normale PS4, weil ich ja so dumm war, mir bei Release eine PS4
zu kaufen. Nee, nee, HDMI kann mittlerweile auch mehr als 60 FPS. Also okay, keine Ahnung,
welche HDMI Version die PS4 hat, das weiß ich nicht. Also die Auflösung, das drüben
sieht einfach ein bisschen schärfer aus, wahrscheinlich weil es ein bisschen mehr Auflösung
hat. Guck mal, was die Leute da schreiben. You may not even notice the difference. Ja
gut, mal davon abgesehen, ich werde mir garantiert keine PS4 Pro holen dafür. Definitiv nicht.
Ja, ein bisschen höhere Auflösung denke ich auch. Naja, mal gucken. Mal gucken, ob das
kommt. Ich finde es klingt relativ plausibel, dadurch, dass morgen Gamescom Pressekonferenz
Stellstag ist, dass das kommt und dann probieren wir das nächste Wochenende mal aus. Gut ist.
Ja, wie gesagt, wir machen noch wieder aufwachen stream, das heißt wir gucken uns jetzt einfach
mal ein paar Sachen an. Habt ihr irgendwelche aktuellen Videos, aktuellen Artikel, aktuellen
Sachen, die wir uns unbedingt im Stream mal angucken müssen? Jetzt kein Ayaya Debate Zeug,
sondern Sachen, wo man sich jetzt im Stream angucken kann. Also kein Ayaya Intensify 3.0
oder so. Blazer Introduction, wir haben sogar schon mal im Stream Blazer ausprobiert, brauchen
wir keine Introduction mehr. Warum kriege ich denn hier die ganzen Stream Twitch Kompilations
angezeigt? Ja, ist lustig, ich denke, ich werfe das mal an. Remember Assault Kills Streaks
in Modern Warfare 3. Modern Warfare 3 war das, wo man auswählen konnte, ob man Support Kills
Streaks oder Assault Kills Streaks wählen. Wie findest du Mixer? Er ist unbedeutend.
Zumindest noch, wer weiß, wie viel da noch hingeht. Also für mich unbedeutend bis zu
dem Zeitpunkt, dass da mal irgendjemand drauf streamt, den ich unbedingt gucken will und
der jetzt auf Mixer ist. Und dann werde ich es mir auch wirklich überlegen, will ich
den wirklich so sehr gucken? Alter, der Bauer ist wieder in seinem Element, er. Flüssig
Helium, Minus 230 Grad, Feldrekord, I9. Hat der eigentlich was Neues? Guck ich auch immer
gern, wenn irgendwelche Sachen overclocked. Ich weiß noch nicht, was in dem Video überhaupt
gehen soll. CPU kühlen mit Chipsats Kühler. Was? What the fuck? Bläst das Ding dann gegen
die CPU oder was? Was auch immer. Das Video ist lustig. Okay, dann gucken wir uns das
Video mal an. Der Auer. Was haben wir sonst noch? Assault Kills Streaks. Ich guck mal
in meine Watchlater Playlist. Linux VM einrichten. Was? Haben wir noch? Oder du meinst nochmal?
Ich bin noch nicht richtig wach, ich kann jetzt noch keine Sachen machen, wo ich mich
super konzentrieren muss bei. Wir können mal wieder Linux VM einrichten, aber aktuell,
aktuell. Das habe ich schon zwei Jahre her, als wir das letzte Mal gemacht haben. Also
ich habe in meiner Watchlater List, habe ich ein paar Sachen noch drin, die ich mir angucken
wollte. Irgendwelches olle PC Zeug, Raspberry Pi Overclocking, irgendwelche alten 3D, Grafikkarten,
Grafikkarten Kram, Spiele Reviews von alten Games. Ach, was ist das? Hä, was ist das?
Da habe ich mir keinen Titel zu aufgeschrieben. Warte mal, was ist das? Das kommt wahrscheinlich
als übelste Video oder so, keine Ahnung. A Day Night in a Life of... Achso, okay, das
ist Arbeitsdebate. Wobei, auf der anderen Seite. Ich meine, sowas habe ich ja früher mal gemacht.
Ganz viel früher, wo ich eine Ausbildung gemacht habe. Als ich meine Ausbildung gemacht habe,
war ich ja bei so einem 24-7 AZ Dienstleister. Und ich meine, als Azubi kann ich keiner zwingen,
nachts zu arbeiten. Ich habe das auch noch ganz selten gemacht. Aber das war eigentlich,
mal gucken. Mal gucken, was es so zeigen. USB, jede Menge USBs wahrscheinlich. Ja,
gut. Ich meine, es sieht halt aus, wie es im Rechenzentrum so aussieht, ne? Und diese
komischen Ohrschützer, die hat man immer nur Alibi-mäßig aufgehabt. Also, man hat
die aufgezogen, wenn man eine Weile drin ist. Aber ich kenne niemand, der quasi immer komplett
vorschriftsmäßig ins AZ gegangen ist und sich erstmal die Ohrschützer aufgesetzt hat.
Was soll es dir eigentlich? Was zeigen Sie denn sonst? Zeigen Sie irgendwas Interessantes?
Ist das ein Dieselmotor? Ne, ist das ein Dieselmotor? Wahrscheinlich ist das ein Diesel fürs AZ oder
oder. Ne, das ist die Klimaanlage. Das ist die Klimaanlage. Das ist kein Dieselmotor.
Das glaube ich eher die Klimaanlage wegen den Schläuchen. Ist im Serverraum so laut?
Relativ laut, ja. Mal gucken, ob man das hier irgendwie hört, wenn der Typ hier drinne steht.
Also, es ist schon relativ laut. Ja, ja. Das war noch Zeiten, als ich an so Gedürrens rumgeforstet
habe. Hast du Glasfaser-Patchpanel? Weiß gar nicht, ob man das bei Glasfasern überhaupt
Patchpanel nennt. Was hat er vor? Ach, der testet. Der testet gerade, wo das rauskommt,
denke ich mal. Das ist, das hast du nämlich auch öfters ein bisschen größeren als jetzt,
auch wenn es, auch wenn es der reinen Lehre nach nicht so sein soll, dass du manchmal nicht
genau weißt, welches Kabel von wo nach wo geht. Muss man das erst ab einer bestimmten
LZ Größe? Was denn? Was meinste? Meinst du jemand haben, der da 24x7 da ist? Ja, ja,
das hast du. Das hast du logischerweise erst ab einer gewissen Größe. Ja, das hast du
erst ab einer gewissen Größe, zumal das meistens auch die Leute machen, die halt richtig
große LZs betreiben. Moin, der Eax ist auch da. Eax, wann geht Woe noch mal los? 27.
oder so, ne? Woe Classic. Dauert noch. Jetzt können wir uns das mal angucken. Restoring
Old PC. 1998 Multimedia PC. Oje, oje, oje. Olle Krem, das gucken wir uns jetzt an. Ich
guck mir irgendwie gerne Olle Hardware an. Ich weiß nicht, warum ich mir gerne Olle
Hardware angucke. Wahrscheinlich weil ich mir dann auch irgendwie alt vorkomme oder nicht
so alt, keine Ahnung. Dann bau doch High End Sachen in einem super alten Case, das erinnert
mich an den Kram, den Nvidia letztens gepostet hat auf Twitter. Sie haben irgendwie geschrieben,
sie haben dann, keine Ahnung, ich sag mal, einen Atari oder so genommen und hätten ihn
jetzt RTXified haben sie geschrieben. Wo ich dann, wo ich mich dann mal dazu hinreißen
habe, lassen zu fragen, was ist denn von dem ursprünglichen PC übrig geblieben? Und hat
im Endeffekt nix. Da haben sie natürlich nicht drauf geantwortet. Aber, ich mein, du kannst
in, keine Ahnung, in den C64 oder so, kannst du keine RTX 2080 anbauen. Was ist Schwachsinn?
Dann bleibt das Gehäuse übrig. Diese uralten Boxen, das war auch so geil damals, da haben
die sich, die Hersteller haben sich überboten mit Wattanzahlen auf so billig kleinen Lautsprechern.
Da stand dann irgendwie auf so einem kleinen, also es ist wahrscheinlich heute immer noch
so, auf so einem kleinen Crap-Lautsprecher stand dann irgendwie drauf 2000 Watt oder
so was. Wo man sich da gerade, ja, ganz bestimmt. Okay, zeig's mal, zeig's mal. Oh, der ist
ja schon, das ist ja schon fast high-end, da haben wir schon USB. Da ist ja schon fast
USB drauf, das ist ja schon fast zu neu, das Ding. Was haben wir denn? PS2, Maus-Tastatur,
USB, wahrscheinlich USB 1. VGA, on-Board, das wird ja schon mal high-performance-Grafik
sein. Drucker, Parallel-Port, Joystick, Serial-Port und die normalen Klinke, Klinke-Stecker.
Mein Klinke-Stecker sind ja heute nicht mehr, nicht mehr so angesagt, Klinke-Stecker sind
ja, sind ja out. Moin, Sibaro. Format C, genau, so war das, Format C. Das war die Zeit,
wo du einmal in der Woche Windows neu installiert hast, weil irgendwas nicht ging. Ach so, was
haben wir da unten? Netzwerkkarte und das? Ist das ein Modem? Oder ist das nochmal ein
zusätzlicher Drucker-Einschluss? Keine Ahnung. Ah, da hatte ich auch einen von.
Also Leute, ernsthaft, das letzte, oder das, was ich als letztes machen würde,
wenn ich einen uralten PC aus Spaß an der Freude zusammenbaue, ist ihn erstmal reinigen,
weil danach kommt er wahrscheinlich eh wieder einmal. Der PC ist verhältnismäßig wenig
gelb für die Zeit. Viele, viele Sachen damals hatten ja ein weißes Gehäuse, die waren gelb,
weil das war erst ein Staub und weil die Leute halt auch geraucht haben, wie sonst was. Moin,
Lacho. Ist ja gar nichts. Erstmal abrubbeln. Auch so eigentlich, nee. Also weder richtet
Zigaretten noch E-Zigaretten, gar nichts. Und ich hab auch noch nie geraucht. Ich hab
mal irgendwann, so mit, keine Ahnung, 15 oder so, hab ich das mal ausprobiert, hab
ich mal gezogen an der Zigarette und hab, also wie man das halt da gemacht hat, man tut
erstmal so, als würde man rauchen, so ein bisschen, ohne es wirklich einzuatmen. Und
irgendwann hab ich mal den Fehler gemacht, dann das einzuatmen und da musste ich husten.
Also was jeder muss, wenn er anfängt zu rauchen, dann hab ich mir gedacht, so warum? Und dann
hab ich nie wieder geraucht, auch nicht dran gezogen, hab ich mal so einen Schwachsinn.
Big Brain. Ja, das, das, ey komm, also für die damalige Zeit ist das, ist das, ist das
gutes Kabelmanagement. Ich mein, da ist ein, äh, ein Zip, ein Kabelbinder drum, da ist
ein Kabelbinder drum, und die Kabel wurden unten lang gelegt, das ist für die damalige,
hochkant installierte Festplatte. Was zum, das hab ich, was, was ist das denn? Das ist
ja eine Fällkonstruktion, ey. Warum hat man nicht einfach hier unten noch nen Case, ne,
so für die Platte? Warum muss die Platte da vorne so hochkant drinnen hängen? Äh,
äh? Was ist denn da drinnen? Eine Ali-Safi-Karte, ne, Ali, das ist hier, was war das? Southbridge
oder sowas. Ähm, AMD-Graf, äh, ATI-Grafikkarte, das war, die Dinger waren damals, die Dinger
waren damals sehr beliebt, die, ähm, diese 3D-Rage-Dingsbums-Grafikkarten onboard. Es
gibt teilweise noch heute Serverboards, die so, die diese Grafik verwenden. Weil halt
wahrscheinlich übertrieben billig, und für VGA und Output reicht's, ähm. Dann Northbridge,
Southbridge, CPU und PC und, nicht mal AGP, nicht mal ein AGP von der Grafikkarte, aiaiaiai.
Crap, Crapware, äh. Ja, das war noch die, das war noch die ollen CPU-Socke, noch die
so mit, die so mit Pins, das ist ja die aktuellen Intel, ich weiß nicht, haben die AMD-CPUs
noch Pins? Wahrscheinlich auch nicht. Weil, ähm, die, die meisten neueren CPUs, die haben
ja nur noch diese Auflage, diese, diese Kontaktflächen und nicht mal keine Pins mehr. AMD hat Pins,
ja? Okay. Boah, ach guck mal, viel G. Ja, die Dinger haben, die haben massiv gesackt,
äh. Gefahrenzone, Vorsicht. Ähm, eh gut, halt Netzteil, aber wahrscheinlich ein übelstes
Crap. G-Power Co. Ltd., was auch immer das sein soll.
Unker Spock. Da fehlt Ramm.
Ja, das, das, das kam da ganz gerne mal vor. Alleins muss man sagen, dass, ähm, ich mein,
die Teile waren damals auch genauso, jetzt auch so gebaut, dass man den letzten Cent rausholt,
ja. Aber insgesamt, dadurch, dass das alles noch ein bisschen kröber war, waren die Teile
zum größten Teil auch ein bisschen stabiler. Dafür sind die Teile heute natürlich eindeutig
mehr leistungsfähiger und ich bevorzuge auch die Teile von heute. Ähm, aber stabiler, stabiler
waren damals vieles. Ich mein, guckt euch mal so einen Parallelport an, da geht nicht
allzu viel kaputt dran. Oder guckt euch auch mal hier die Verpackung von der CPU an, da
geht auch nicht allzu viel kaputt dran. Ähm, ja, aber, war ein Lamm.
Ah, schöne IDE-Kabel. Festschweißt.
Genauso im Bau. Der Bau übertaktilist noch auf 5 Gigahertz.
Das ist ja eine beknackte Technik, eine Festplatte festzumachen.
SCSI-Karte? Da konnte man damals schon CDs brennen und gleichzeitig was auf die Platte
schreiben. Kann sich noch jemand, wahrscheinlich nicht, ich frag's nochmal, ähm, kann sich
noch jemand an die ersten CD-Brenner erinnern, wo man, wo man sagen musste, äh, hier CD-Brennen
starten und dann hat man einfach mal 45 Minuten bis 2 Stunden mit dem Rechner nichts gemacht,
weil man sonst Angst hatte, dass man den Rohling schrottet. Was ist das? Äh, das ist quasi
sowas. Das ist quasi SATA, die, die ältere Version
von SATA. Stimmt zwar nicht so ganz, aber, ähm, in SATA hat er ein bisschen was überlebt
von, ja. Also es ist die ältere SATA-Variante, nur
mit dem Unterschied, dass man dort an einen Anschluss ganz viele Geräte hintereinander
stecken konnte. Gucken wir mal, ob die hier ein Bild davon haben. Du konntest, du konntest
ja damals, ah, aber das ist jetzt, hat ja keiner, keiner ein geschönte, äh, schönes Bild,
du zumindest genau das konntest du machen. Du konntest hier quasi hintereinander mehrere
Geräte anschließen und das war, sag mal, die damalige Server-Enterprise-Technik-Laufwerke
und, und, äh, Zusatzgeräte anzuschließen. Das hatte nämlich den Vorteil, ähm, dass
die Sachen auch parallel funktioniert haben, ja. Also sprich, ähm, man hatte mehrere Festplatten
in der Hand, oder man hat einen CD-Laufwerk, einen CD-Brenner und, und, ähm, eine Festplatte
in der Hand und du konntest das gleichzeitig benutzen. Also, STSI war deutlich, deutlich
besser als, als die ganze, der ganze EDE-Crap, den es damals gegeben hat. Es war natürlich
auch teurer. Du hast nicht nur eine Controllerkarte gekauft, du hast gebraucht, du hast auch extra
Hardware dafür gebraucht. Das war halt, das war die, die Enterprise-Server-Variante.
Ja, die, die, die waren damals übelst beliebt. Waffa Anwaran, genau.
Oder Windows, oder Windows, Windows-Boot-Disc-Kette. Kannst du da noch einer gerade erinnern? Windows-Boot-Disc-Kette.
Da muss ich aber sagen, dafür bin ich auch noch ein bisschen zu jung für Windows-Boot-Disc-Kette.
Also, ich hab das noch mitgekriegt, ich hab das auch ein paar Mal gemacht, aber die meisten
Rechner, die ich hatte, konnten ohne Probleme von CD-Booten. War USB außen vor, ja. Damals
war es ja schon froh, wenn man von CD-Booten konnte.
Die sieht aus ein bisschen wie Teppichmesser. Oh, das ist richtig shiny hier.
Ja, die geht bestimmt nicht mehr. Zahnbürste, krass. Auf die Idee wär ich nie gekommen,
bei der Zahnbürste nachher rumzurubbeln.
Socke sieben, ja. Das ist mit Sicherheit besser, als das Ding aus dabei war.
Was ist denn das? Was für ein RAM ist denn das, was da reinkommt? Ist das schon DDR1?
Nee, oder? Das ist noch davor. Ah ja, SD. Das ist noch normaler SD-RAM. Naja, das ist
kein DDR1. Alter, ist das DDR1? Das sieht nicht aus, das sieht nicht aus wie DDR1. Ja,
weil DDR1 hatte andere Nippel. Ja, genau, das ist kein DDR1. Das ist 133 dRAM.
Ich hätte überhaupt keine IDE-Festplatte mehr, um sowas zu restaurieren.
Was ich mir überlegt hab, wegen Channel-Emotes, weil ich übertrieben unkreativ bin mit Channel-Emotes.
Es gab aber im Discord schon ein paar gute Vorschläge für Emotes und so ein paar Ideen
hab ich auch. Ich hätte gerne ein paar Emotes, die ein paar Programmiersprachen verarschen,
die irgendwie natürlich so die üblichen Wubbler-S, Schwitze-Emotes, Max-Smoke, solche Dinge.
Also Wubb-Smoke, Wubb-S, irgendwie sowas. Ich hab mir überlegt, wir könnten mal zusammen
auf Fiverr gehen und mal gucken, was es dort für Leute gibt, die Twitch-Emotes machen.
Und dann beauftrage ich einfach, ich hab 11 Emote-Slots mittlerweile schon, und dann beauftragen
wir einfach mal Leute auf Fiverr-Emotes zu machen und gucken, was da rauskommt.
Fiverr, Fiverr, ich glaub es heißt Fiverr. Guck mal hier, Twitch-Emotes.
Nee, da gibt es richtig gute Leute, ohne Scheiß. Da gibt es richtig, da gibt es richtig gute
Leute und es ist auch gar nicht mal so teuer.
Weil für ordentliche Emotes kann man auch mal Kohle bezahlen. Keine Ahnung, wir sagen
jetzt irgendwie Fiverr's Choice, sagen wir mal der Typ da. Da hat er ein paar Beispiele
drin, was er schon alles gemacht hat für Emotes.
Da muss man natürlich, ich hab da grad was gesehen. Ich dachte, das ist ein Tracer-Emote.
Keine Ahnung, die haben jetzt hier unterschiedliche Tiers, was man sich auswählen kann. 6 Twitch-Emotes,
3 Twitch-Emotes, 1 Twitch-Emote. Und ich würde mal einen Twitch-Emote bei dem beauftragen
zum Beispiel und dann gucken wir mal was rauskommt. 3 Tage, 3 Tage kann ich warten, das macht
jetzt auch nicht fett. Das macht jetzt auch nicht fett. Und er hat, er schreibt hier
irgendwo, dass er auch einen Brifue-Sketch machen würde. Ich find das cool, das können
wir mal ausprobieren. Lass uns mal auf Fiverr Twitch-Emotes machen. Und dann schauen wir
mal was rauskommt. Das ist so eine beknackte Idee, eine Festplatte so zu mounten im Gehäuse.
Die Dinger damals hatten ja auch noch ein Problem damit, wenn sie nicht in der normalen
Lage betrieben wurden, wo sie gedacht waren. Ist halt im Prinzip immer noch so, aber mir
ist noch nie ehrlich gesagt eine Festplatte kaputt gegangen deswegen. Papa, nur die Twitch-Priame,
dankeschön, nice. Dankeschön Twitch-Priame. Primers sind wieder am Start hier. Überträgt
das nicht extrem die Vibration und das Klackern in den Raum? Garantiert. Das Ding, das wird
wahrscheinlich vorne. Und bei jedem Schreibvorgang wird es dann machen. Warte mal, er hat's
verstanden. Was ich meine, glaube ich. Da hast du die Geräusche wieder geholt. Watt?
Moin Holger. 79. Aber hier die haben sogar Farben, dass man weiß, was was ist hier. Irgendwie
vermisse ich das auch. Allerdings muss ich dazu sagen, ich vermisse das überhaupt nicht
wegen der Hardware und ich vermisse die Zeit auch überhaupt nicht wegen Windows 95, 98,
sondern einfach alles drum herum und weil man halt selbst noch ein bisschen jünger war.
Ansonsten bevorzuge ich eindeutig die Hardware, die es heute gibt im Vergleich zu dem olden
Crap. Oh. Ich hab gar keine. Ich hab gar keine CRT mehr. Oh, es bootet.
Wo sind da die LEDs? Naja, hier siehst du doch. Mehr RGB, mehr RGB war da nix. Muss
reichen, dass du ein Power-LED hast. Wann hast du deinen ersten PC bekommen? Ich hab
keine Ahnung mehr, wie alt ich da gewesen bin. Das war ein. Ich glaube, das war auch
ein K6133. K6133? Gab's sowas? Nee. Nee. Was gab's denn da für welche? Pentium
133. Es war auf jeden Fall ein AMD, den ich hatte. Oder K5, was ist ein K5? 200, 166,
dann könnte es ein 166 vielleicht gewesen sein. K5? Oh, was es da gab? K5? Dann war
das, ich glaub, dann war das so einer, den ich hatte. Ich bilde mir ein, das war ein
103. Jaja, so einer war das. Ja, genau. Das war der erste PC. So, wann hab ich bis wann
wurden die Dinger produziert? Wahrscheinlich 96 oder so. Ja, 96. Ich denke mal, dass ich
den so 96 gekriegt hab, weil zu Half-Life 1, und das war 97, 98, also so während dann
Half-Life 1 quasi gerade angesagt war, hab ich nen Pentium 2400 gekriegt. Das heißt,
96 war das. Ich überleg grad, ich glaube, das war auch wirklich der allererste, den
ich hatte. 96, 84 bin ich geboren, da war ich 12. Quickmuffs. Mit 12, ja. Ich hab auch
ein bisschen rumgenervt daheim, weil ich sowas haben will. Ich glaub, 12 ist so ein normales
Alter, oder? Oder wann habt ihr euer erstes PC gekriegt? Cyrix, ja die gibt's nicht mehr.
Ja, auf meinem ersten PC lief die Diablo 2 auch nicht flüssig, das lag aber da dran,
weil die Diablo 2, wann kam die Diablo 2 raus? 98, 99, 2000, ja, weil ich zu wenig
RAM hatte. Ich hatte damals nur irgendwie 256 MB RAM, und Diablo 2 war relativ RAM-hungrig.
Hat es sich früher eigentlich gelohnt, selber PC zusammen? Klar, immer. Es hat sich schon
immer gelohnt, PC selbst zusammen zu bauen. Mit 16, okay. Da war ich ja mit 12 vielleicht
relativ früh. Ja, aber so eine CPU war da drin. Das war auch eine Zeit, da war AMD relativ
beliebt und auch ziemlich gut. Naja, das war glaub ich noch Edoram oder so. Weiß gar
nicht, was die Dinger für RAM unterstützt haben. Sag ich mal, steht da irgendwie was?
Das war noch Edoram. Das waren so ganz kleine Putzriegelchen, die Dinger. Die aussehen
wie alt, aber sie sind ja auch alt. Ich kann sagen, die halt alt aussehen, aber sie sehen
nicht immer alt aus, sie sind alt. Warum habe ich Windows-Sounds, wenn ich suche und nicht
finde? Das habe ich auf meinem anderen Rechner abgestellt. Das ist ja unnervig, wie macht
man das aus? Search sounds Chrome. How to mute Ding sound. Das geht nicht über Chrome
direkt. Omega Nudel. Naja, das war mein erster Rechner. Der hatte so eine CPU hier drin,
ich glaube eine 133 MHz CPU. Ich glaube 16 oder 32 MB RAM. Und ich glaube 0,8 G Festplatte.
Also im Vergleich zu manch anderem haben wir doch relativ überschaubar, aber für die damalige
Zeit war das wirklich schnell. Dungeon Keeper, ja Dungeon Keeper auch gespielt. Dungeon Keeper
ist ein ultra-neisses Game. Ist bis heute eigentlich eines meiner Lieblingsgames. Ist
eigentlich bis heute eines meiner Lieblingsgames. Chrome Sound Effects. Gebaded. Ach was auch
immer. Gucken wir mal weiter. Weißt du, ob man das noch irgendwie spielen kann? Ja klar
kann man das noch spielen. Du kannst hier bei GOG kannst du dir das kaufen und dann
lädst du dir Keeper FX runter. Das ist ein Grafikmod für das erste Dungeon Keeper. Dann
läuft das auch in 1080p und sieht verhältnismäßig gut aus. Also für Dungeon Keeper Verhältnisse.
Also für Dungeon Keeper 1 sieht das schon ziemlich gut aus. Und es ist halt das originale
Game nur grafisch ein bisschen aufgebohrt. Also Dungeon Keeper 1 war ein richtig, richtig
nicees Game. Ja da kann ich mich ja auch noch dran erinnern, dass der am Anfang immer rumgelabert
hat. Dass man irgendwelche IDE Drives erkennt hat und dass man das skippen kann. Ich wüsste
nicht wozu man es skippen kann. Und die beste Fehlermeldung immer noch war Fehler. Keine
Tastatur gefunden. F1 drücken um fortzufahren. Da fand ich mich immer massiv, massiv gebated
am. Kennst du ein gutes Free Programm, wo man zwischen Windows und Linux seine Maustastatur
und Synergy. Synergy ist das einzige was mir einfällt, was Cross-Platform Windows und Linux
kann. Was da. Ey musst du nicht kaufen, gibt es auch die kostenlose Varianten. Jaja, gibt
es eine kostenlose Variante davon. Du musst gucken, die meisten sind sogar schon im Repo
mit drinne. Also es gibt eine kostenpflichtige und kostenlose Version. Die kostenlose Version
haben sie nur ein bisschen versteckt. Barrier. Barrier kenne ich noch gar nicht. Zeig mal.
Das würde ich zuerst probieren. Windows, Mac, Linux, BSD alles was man braucht. Das würde
ich zuerst probieren. Das scheint mir auch ein Synergy Fork zu sein. Das sieht mir sympathischer
aus das Projekt. Das würde ich mal ausprobieren. Habe ich noch nicht getestet. Aber wenn ich
sowas bräuchte würde ich jetzt mal ausprobieren. Das war doch ja. Das blaue BIOS. Ich meine
heute ist ja so ein BIOS schon, wenn du es so willst. Also die aktuellen Sachen, das ist
ja schon so ein halbes Betriebssystem. Du hast USB Unterstützung in einem BIOS heute. Du
hast also USB Tastatur und Maus Unterstützung im BIOS. Du hast hohe Auflösungen, also relativ
hohe Auflösungen im BIOS. Du hast, keine Ahnung, 24 Spit Farbtiefe im BIOS. Du kannst
Netzwerk, DHCP, Adresse ziehen und BIOS Update über das Internet machen. Aus dem BIOS, also
aus dem EFI raus. Also mittlerweile ist das wirklich halbes Betriebssystem. Das war doch
zu dieser Zeit ein wenig mehr basic. So wie der Name basic. Also B in BIOS ja auch basic
heißt. One Hand Project sagt perfekt endlich mal ein Stream, der morgens meinen Kopf so
beansprucht, dass ich direkt wach bin. Ja das ist ja auch, deswegen ist ja auch der
Aufwachs-Stream. Nur für 5-Hat High IQs. Aber die Rechner damals hatten zum größten
Teil alle Backdoor Geschichten. Also da hatten die Hersteller immer so Standard BIOS Passwörter
vergeben, wenn du im Internet gesucht hast nach BIOS Passwörter. Dafür hast du meistens
welche gefunden später. Was auch funktioniert hat ist manchmal BIOS Batterie raus und noch
mal einschalten und so Dinger. Mal gucken wie er das macht, mal gucken wie er das macht.
Wahrscheinlich gibt es irgendwie einen Weg das Ding zu resetten. Ich hasse die neuen
digitalen BIOS. Moment. Digital war das schon immer. Alles. Das war ja kein Analog BIOS
oder sowas. Ja. Jumper. Genau. Reset Jumper. Eeeh. Kannst du das mal machen. Ja. Ja. Ja.
Eeeh. Boot Disk Kette.
Die
Ich habe einen originalen Windows 98-Disk probiert, und das hat auch nicht geredet.
Im Endeffekt, kein CD, den ich probiert habe, war geredet.
Und ich habe die Kabel gewechselt und ein paar Setzungen gemacht.
Nein, es scheint, dass der CD-Druck tot ist.
Also das ist lustig.
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich eher drauf getippt, falsche Jumper, falsche IDE-Jumper-Settings
an der Festplatte und am, oder an dem CD-Laufwerk.
Ich mein, das kennt heute kaum noch einer, aber man musste damals
an seiner Festplatte und an seinem CD-Laufwerk, musste man Jumper setzen, dass das funktionierte.
Das war richtiger Kretz damals.
Liegt.
Ja, genau.
Get out.
Ich bin beeindruckt, wie viel Hardware der Typ hat.
Und was auch witzig ist,
dieser CD-Speed, das war damals, war das so eine gewisse Art von Schwanzvergleich,
wer einen höheren Speed auf seinem CD-Laufwerk stehen hat.
Der eine hatte nur 24-fach, der andere 32-fach, und dann kam eine 48-fach, der nächste 52-fach.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was das Schnellste war, ich glaube 52-fach oder so war das Schnellste.
Und da fand man sich dann immer viel geiler, wenn man ein schnelleres CD-Laufwerk hatte als die anderen.
Und man muss sagen, selbst 48- oder 52-fach CD-Laufwerke, das war immer noch lahm.
Das war übertrieben lahm.
Sequenziell war es okay, aber Exist-Zeiten waren halt jenseits von Gut und Böse beim CD-Laufwerk.
Eine CD zerrissen im CD-Laufwerk, das habe ich auch nicht geschrieben.
72-fach!
Boah, BÄM!
Oh, CD-Shattering at 1.000.000...
Nee, Moment, mit wie viel FPS?
Mit 170.000 FPS.
Okay, das müssen wir uns jetzt mal kurz angucken, ohne das Geschwätze im Vorfeld.
Direkt!
mir
Superman
direkt
kamu
Ich
hab
es
ist
super
dem
von
war
das die die dinger die war noch Licht, scharfchat ich ne und ich sag
Mach mal so, wer schon mal versucht hat, eine CD von Hand durchzubrechen, das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Ach, brecht mal eine CD mit der Hand durch, ohne euch zu schneiden. Ich übernehme keine Gewährleistung für körperliche Schäden, die ihr davontragt. Aber das ist schwierig.
Das ist wirklich cool, man sieht, wie es durchreißt, an welcher Stelle es kaputt geht.
Es reißt hier unten und dann... cool. Und die Dinger sind recht scharf, kannte ich ja auch. Wenn das schon mal draufgedreht ist, hat es keinen Spaß.
Übrigens, wo ich letztens draufgedreht bin, da bin ich letztens draufgedreht.
Da. Auf so einen Teil, letztens draufgedreht. Das ist irgendwie vom Schreibtisch runtergefallen und lag dann hier auf dem Teppich unterm Schreibtisch.
Da habe ich mich mit dem Stuhl herangefahren, um sich mit dem Stuhl heranzufahren, und da hing das Ding am Teppich und das hat richtig geknackst.
Für was ist das? Da kannst du Pins miteinander verbinden. Und dann ist das Ding in der Ferse drin gesteckt. Da habe ich gemerkt, dass es unterschiedlich schnell geht, dass man was merkt und es wehtut.
Du merkst es viel schneller, dass dich was berührt an der Ferse, als dass es wehtut. Das ist so eine halbe Sekunde Verzögerung.
Und als ich es knacken gehört habe, wusste ich, in einer halben Sekunde tut mir die Ferse weh. Das hat dann auch wehgetan.
Der Edge Lord. Twitch Prime. Danke schön. Fuck. Ja, aber es war nichts Schlimmes. Einfach wieder rausgezogen, so gut es ist, aber es hat noch ein, zwei Tage wehgetan beim Drauftreten, aber dann war es wieder okay.
Aber ich würde es keinem empfehlen, auf der Erde so Zeug rumliegen zu lassen. Das ist eine schlechte Idee.
Aber wie gesagt, 48-fach war es, hat es damals schon ganz schön, ganz schön huge brain.
StarTech. Ich glaube, ich hatte im Leben noch keinen StarTech-Kühler.
Cooler. Na ja, gut, gibt Schlimmeres.
Brauchst du jede zumindest installieren. Was Spaß.
Wie der wieder CRT blinkt. Wahrscheinlich irgendwie mit 60 Hertz oder so im Installer.
Du musstest an so vielen Dingern damals rumfuddeln. Das war der Wahnsinn. Und wie gesagt, einmal in der Woche Windows neu installieren, weil irgendwas nicht funktioniert hat.
Und das haben ja damals nur die Noobs gemacht, von der offiziellen Hersteller-CD zu installieren. Du hast raw Windows installiert und dann versucht, wenn du schon einen Monat mal hattest, alle Treiber zu saugen.
Das Klipp-Arts-Pocken.
Das ist quasi Cortana Lite oder was?
Das ist wieder so Crapware, den der Hersteller mitgeliefert hat. Das war damals noch, noch ätzender, weil die Rechner halt viel schlechter waren von der Hardware her als heute, was da mitgeliefert wird.
Die waren teilweise zugekleistert mit Müll. Deswegen hat ja auch, deswegen hat eigentlich jeder von der Original-CD installiert und sich danach die Treiber geholt.
Und jeder Installer, guck, da war die Müllanne dabei. Das Kido-Net, das hier für die Pedobears.
Was auch nicht fehlen durfte, ist der Registrier-Button. Damals war es noch nicht so, dass man für alles zwangsweise einen Account gebraucht hat.
Also heute wollen ja viele Seiten, dass man sich registriert, so nach dem Motto, sie möchten bei uns aufs Klo gehen, bitte vorher einmal registrieren mit echter Name und echter Adresse.
Damals war es aber so, dass sich alles genervt hat. Bitte registrieren Sie sich jetzt.
Guck mal da hier, Backup-Bell-Registration, das Cyber-Coach.
Könntest du da CS052 dich coachen lassen, oder? Die Wolle1901, Switch Prime, Dankeschön. Big Brain, High IQ, Subscriber. Nice, danke.
Achso und einmal wieder für den Chat, weil wir Low on Cuties runnen. Prime 1996 schreibt, habe letztens einen Artikel gelesen, dass nach einer Studie 40% oder 60% unter Unternehmen noch XP benutzen.
Also es kommt immer drauf, das glaube ich nicht so ganz. Es ist die Frage, wie breit man das auslegt.
Also wenn man sagt, es gibt irgendwo in einem Unternehmen noch mindestens einen Rechner, der Windows XP hat, dann glaube ich das.
Weil da stehen oftmals ganz olle Sachen rum, das heißt irgendwelche Telefonanlagen oder guckt euch die Bankautomaten an oder sowas.
Aber die meisten Arbeitsplätze sind definitiv nicht mehr. Also ein großer Teil der Arbeitsplätze sind garantiert nicht mehr XP.
Das meine ich so mit Bloatware hier, dieser Crap daneben. Shutdown.
Vor allem, ganz wichtig, der mittelste, präsenteste, wichtigste Knopf muss natürlich Shutdown sein.
Und daneben muss auch nochmal ein ganz wichtiger Kopf registrieren, sowas. Das ist, das ist, das ist, do it.
Just do it. Do it. Was genau möchtet ihr, was möchten sie uns damit sagen?
www.com Software Support Center Navigation.
Ok, das war so eine typische Crapware, die dabei war, die kein Mensch gebraucht hat.
Ihr benutzt zu 25% noch XP. Ja, aber bestimmt nicht an Rechner, die ins Internet gehen, oder?
Weil ich mein, sonst ist, ist ja Instant-Drip.
Für irgendwelche Offline-Kisten, die am Arsch der Welt stehen, für irgendwelche Spezialsoftware, ihr geht damit ins Internet.
Ja, das ist ja schon grob fahrlässig, ja.
Das ist, äh, nur auf Frage der Zeit, bis MonkaSmoak angesagt ist.
Der Clocks HD ist am Start morgen.
It's just filled up. Look at all those icons in the taskbar and all those shortcuts on the desktop and that weird ribbon thing on here.
It's just, oh no. But hey, you can switch your wallpaper on the fly, so that's worth it.
It did come with a few pre-installed pieces of software I was not familiar with. It's kind of intriguing.
Man sieht, wie lahm der Rechner ist durch die ganzen vorinstallierten Crap, ne?
Die, die Dinger waren damals, wenn die Hardware halbwegs gescheit war, mit einem frisch installierten Windows 8, äh, mit einem frisch installierten Windows 98, waren die, also ohne das, was im Hintergrund lief, waren die Dinger relativ responsive und relativ schnell.
Ich mein, okay, es war keine SSD drin, es war eine Platte drin, das heißt, wenn du was gestartet hast, hast du oftmals immer noch gemerkt, dass das halt erstmal von der Platte lädt, aber es war kein so riesen Unterschied.
Damals, gut, ich mein, der Unterschied ist ja auch ganz klar, wenn du ein Programm hast, was einfach mal 80 MB hat und erstmal massig Zeug in RAM laden muss beim Starten, zu einem Programm, was irgendwie 20 KB groß ist, ist klar, dass es doch auf alter Hardware schnell ist.
Ordneröffnung, die Maus hängt erstmal, ja, das war halt, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du Preview Bildchen und von der Festplatte, ja. Aber ansonsten waren die Dinger relativ, relativ zackig und responsive damals, wenn ihr nicht so, guckt euch nicht mehr zu, gemüllt war mit dem, mit dem Mist da unten.
New from the Net
Was auch immer.
Ja, das stimmt, das ist so, das ist so.
Das ist echt so, das ist so ein typischer Startbildschirm aus der Zeit damals.
Wo sie alle gedacht haben, sie müssten super, super Multimedia sein.
Use your calculator
Der Tutorial wie bei mir, wenn du aus der Tasche reichst, ja, richtig.
Und klick scientific
Das ist genug von dem, wir gehen direkt in die MS Config und starten das Disable-Junk, denn es dauert viel zu lange, um das Ding von einem kühlen Boot zu starten, wie zwei Minuten. Disable-Startup-Optionen, einbauen, ein Bunch von Programmen, einfach, um es ein bisschen cleaner zu machen, damit wir mehr Sachen hier anbieten können, wie Commander Keen, Goodbye Galaxy, etwas, das ich immer auf Computern versuche, die ich zusammengelegt habe, nur weil ich weiß, wie es aussehen und runnen sollte. Und ja, hier ist, wie es sieht und klingt.
Ah, ich hab nie gespielt, auch wenn das meine Zeit war, aber damals habe ich eher das Zeug auf dem Super-Interno gespielt.
So, while the AdLib compatibility is pretty decent, I would say, there is a problem with the graphics, and that is very, very...
...becoming across a huge variety of video graphics adapters, and it is one of those things where it's the SVGA compatibility causing problems.
And you can switch around some options, and the option for you to try to alleviate that, but it didn't work. There's still stuttering and weird screen tearing, no matter what combination of options I use.
So games like this may not run very well on here. However, something like Jill of the Jungle, I was surprised at how well that works.
This is one of those games that can be very hard to get, looking and sounding correctly, and here you go.
So the game's running at the proper speed, that's nice, that does not always happen with systems of this kind of configuration.
And then there is the AdLib sound, which, you know, while it doesn't sound exactly like an OBL2, so maybe it's not the most accurate to that, it's doing some interesting things.
Das müsst ihr mal ausprobieren. Windows 98 ins Internet gehen.
Boah, das wird mich mal interessieren, wie die Webseiten aussehen im Internet Explorer. Was ist denn das, EE5 oder so?
EE4?
This sounds kind of robotic-y, crunchy, electronic and weird, and I don't know, I sort of like that.
Boah, der Sound!
Of course, something else I gotta try for DOS-Game compatibility is Duke Nukem 3D, because sometimes it'll run oddly slow or choppy, and I'm gonna try it out right here, and here you go.
Boah, der Sound ist schon ganz schön kaputt.
I did run into just a little bit of unexpected slowdown in 640x480 VESA mode, but, you know, it's fine.
I mean, it's Duke Nukem 3D, there's no weird flickering, and it's totally playable, so this one gets a pass.
Next up, though, I wanted to try POD, and this is a game that is notoriously difficult to run, even on computers of its time, like this one.
But oddly enough...
...es sei denn, sie sind mittlerweile auch bei Google soweit, dass du JavaScript unbedingt brauchst.
Ich mein, muss ich mal überlegen, wie das damals ausgesehen hat.
Wir gucken mal, wie das damals ausgeschaut hat, ja.
98.
Zeig her.
Kann sein, dass ich den Adblocker ausmachen muss, dass es funktioniert.
Ach so, in dem Moment, Google gibt's ja noch gar nicht so lang, ne?
Das war die erste Google-Seite.
Lustig.
War beides Suchergebnisse. Heat, Sweat, Coffee, Moonsault. Das war, wo wir E-Mouse gesucht haben. Was passiert, wenn ich da jetzt was draufsuche?
Man kann auf Google von 1998, kann man nach Tests suchen.
Pock.
Man kriegt leider nicht angezeigt, wie viel suche... hier.
25 Millionen Ergebnisse.
Ich mein, da sieht man mal, dass ich so viel jetzt nicht getan hab. Man erkennt immer noch eindeutig, dass es Google ist, ne? Und das ist Google 98.
Und wo man auch dran sieht, die sind sehr, sehr zurückhaltend, was Änderungen von ihrem Hauptprodukt, ihrer Suchmaschine angeht.
Mittlerweile hast du ein bisschen Vorschau, hast du die ganze... oh, Cache hatten sie damals auch schon. Ah nee, das war 2000. Okay, das war 2000.
Ist schon ein bisschen neuer. Das ist jetzt 2000, ja, anscheinend.
Ja, das ist zwei Jahre später. Aber ist trotzdem nice. Nach eins suchen. Eins geht immer.
Das ist auch 2000, ja.
Aber ich find's cool, sich den alten Mist teilweise mal anzugucken. Gucken wir uns mal TwitchTV an.
Ach, Quatsch, was mach ich denn da?
Das war JustinTV damals.
TwitchTV.
Oh, die erste Variante von 2002.
Hatte das erste Google schon Easter Eggs. Könnte ich mir tatsächlich... oh.
CGI, du mein' Git.
Hier, da war nicht viel mit Twitch Emotes.
Geht nicht. Ich glaub' Twitch geht nicht, weil die komisches Redirecting drin haben.
WTV, was? Nee, nee, nee, nee. VariSci, was zum...
Ach, das gab's damals einfach noch gar nicht. Ab wann gibt's denn TwitchTV?
Das war JustinTV, was ja vorher... Ach, das ist erst 2011 gestartet. Stimmt, das gibt's ja noch gar nicht so lang.
Ja, TwitchTV.
Erste TwitchTV-Variante. Bam. Contact Us.
StarCraft 2. League of Legends. Guckt euch mal an, die meistgespielten Games.
Also die meist... oh, guck mal, Streams. StarCraft 2 war damals angesagt hier. 300, 319.
Black Ops. Black Ops 1. 53.
Ja, so sah Twitch damals aus. Wobei, da fehlt jede Menge CSS und sonst was von der Seite, der nicht mitarchiviert wurde.
Battlefield 3. Guck mal, hier 11.000, StarCraft 2. Battlefield 3, fünf Leute. Huge.
Oh, Alter. Der Channel.
Halo Reach war damals Dark Souls. Ja, da gab's hier diese ganzen LOL-Geschichten noch.
Das find ich cool. Ja, leider haben sie bei Twitch nicht so viel archiviert. Bei YouTube ist mehr archiviert.
Wir gucken erst mal das Video fertig. Ach nee, guck mal, was ist denn das?
Ach, das ist mein Channel hier von 2010.
Ja, da hatte ich sogar noch gar nicht den richtigen Keks als Avatar.
Da hatte ich noch gar nicht den Keks als Avatar. Da hatte ich noch diesen Linux-Keks.
Der Max und der Friseur. Und ganz wichtig, damals zum Videos abspielen auf YouTube, hat man den Adobe Flash Player gebraucht.
Gun Game Commentary. Vor 14 Stunden. Zack. New Town Special.
Das war das YouTube-Playout, wo man noch richtig viel customisieren konnte am Channel.
2638 Subs hier.
Most subscribed this month. Germany. Most subscribed. 55.
Ich fand diese Awards eigentlich ziemlich cool, die sie damals hatten.
Generell war YouTube zu dieser Zeit viel persönlicher. Sowohl die Leute, die subscribten, als auch die Plattformen zu den Leuten, die Videos gemacht haben.
Was für comments gepostet hat.
Wer kann gut Channel-Hinterkunde erstellen? Wer doch Partner? Ja, wurde ich ja dann später auch.
Friend request. Farmers gameplay please. Farmers.
An manche Namen kann ich mich noch erinnern. Zum Beispiel Silent Bob. Der Name sagt man auch.
Rest jetzt nicht so. Damals war YouTube noch näher an der Community.
Das erste Max-FPS-Video findest du nur übers Archiv. Ja, das stimmt.
Hier ist der Text. Ah ja, wir gucken uns mal an, was der Zombie für ein Problem hat.
Vielleicht können wir was dazu sagen. Aber ich kann schon gleich sagen, Remote-Diagnosen sind immer schwierig.
Moin, vielleicht kannst du mir helfen. Und zwar, ich habe meinen Ryzen 9 3900X, ordentliche CPU hier, im PC eingebaut, bevor alles regelmäßig BIOS geupdatet.
Und wo ich den PC hochgefahren habe, kam der Blue Screen vor mir hinaus. Dann habe ich den PC zurück gesetzt und wollte mir das neu installieren.
Dann kam Fenster zum Installieren und nach dem Installieren startete der PC und ich kam wieder in das Installations-Menü.
Du könntest mal versuchen mit einer Linux Live USB-Stick zu starten, nur um prinzipiell zu gucken, ob der PC ordentlich hochfährt.
Ansonsten ist es ein typischer Fall, wo Remote-Diagnose ziemlich schwierig ist. Ich vermute mal, dass du ein altes, letzte Ryzen-Generationen-Mainboard hast und da einen neuen Ryzen reingebaut hast.
Da habe ich gelesen, es gibt ab und zu mal Probleme. Aber zumal du ins Installations-Menü gekommen bist, sollte das CPU-technisch eigentlich funktionieren.
Kommt mal wieder ein neues Video. Ja, mal kommt mit Sicherheit ein neues Video.
Also das kann man jetzt remote sehr schlecht diagnostizieren. Ich würde mal versuchen, eine Linux USB-Stick rein zu feuern und gucken, ob der Rechner überhaupt bootet.
Und dann kannst du ja mal probieren mit dem Recovery, mit dem Windows Recovery-Modus, der da startet, wenn Windows nicht richtig hochfährt, einfach nur mal Booten fixen.
Aber es ist wirklich schwierig, da zu remote was dazu zu sagen.
Ich gucke jetzt mal, ist das Video fertig? Stimmt, was ist mein, was ist mein, was ist mein erstes Video, was ich noch auf dem Channel habe?
Ach Quatsch. Ja, das stimmt gar nicht, das ist das dritte oder vierte Video gewesen.
Das erste Video, da hatte ich Musik von den Toten Hosen drin und von den apokalyptischen Reitern.
Das musste ich löschen, oder musste ich nicht löschen, ich wollte es nicht umlassen wegen Copyright.
Das nächste war, irgendetwas rumgesnipert auf Creek, glaube ich, oder G36-Gamper auf Creek, wo ich irgendwas über Headsets erzählt habe, da hatte ich auch Musik drin.
Ich glaube, danach kam das oder es kam noch mehr dazwischen, ich weiß es nicht genau.
Ah, der Medal of Honor Reboot, Flammenwerfer Only. Da kamen noch ein paar Videos mehr dazwischen, glaube ich.
Leute, wisst ihr was, wie viele Videos habe ich, sieht man das irgendwie, irgendwie die Anzahl an Videos?
Keine Ahnung, ich kann mich an jedes einzelne Video noch erinnern, wenn ich hier durchscrolle.
Zum Beispiel, ich kann mich an jedes einzelne Video, wenn ich mir das angucke und den Titel lese, kann ich mich an jedes einzelne Video noch erinnern.
Obwohl ich irgendwas, sind das 700 Videos oder sowas, obwohl ich da schon ein paar habe.
Da haben wir, genau da habe ich was, StarCraft.
Das ist, deswegen mag ich übrigens kein Endlos Scroll, wegen diesem Crap hier.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Guck mal, mein Browser kackt schon ab dabei.
Jetzt haben wir es geschafft, hier runter zu scrollen. Und ich bin ja jemand, der jetzt nicht jeden Tag 5 Let's Plays hochgeladen hat, also ich habe noch relativ wenig Videos.
Probier mal sowas bei Kronk, probier mal sowas bei Kronk, zurückzuspulen bis zum letzten Video.
Kannst du knicken?
Die Opfer Edition, ja.
Ach ja.
Schade, dass YouTube nicht mehr die Plattform ist, die mir gefallen hat.
Ich bin immer noch am Überlegen, wie ich weiter mache.
Also ich werde den Channel nicht löschen oder so ein Blödsinn.
Ich bin immer noch am Überlegen, wie ich da gescheit weiter mache auf YouTube.
Geht das komisch um alle Zeugchen, guckt mich jetzt nicht.
Doom muss natürlich einmal gespielt werden, das läuft aber auch ordentlich drauf.
Was ist das? Age of Empires?
Ah, das war das erste Age of Empires.
Freust du dich auf das neue Plants vs. Zombies?
Ich habe das, ich habe da überhaupt noch nichts gesehen.
Ist das ein richtiges Plants vs. Zombies oder ist das ein...
Oder ist das ein Garden Warfare oder Neues?
Das ist doch alles Jibay, das gibt doch überhaupt kein Plants vs. Zombies 3.
Ach so, okay.
Aber vielleicht kommt ja auf der Gamescom irgendwas.
Ja, aber deswegen gucke ich mir gerne so olle Videos an.
Also Leute, gucke ich mir Videos an, wo sie irgendwelche ollen Rechner oder so zeigen.
Da erinnert man sich oftmals daran, dass damals auch nicht alles toll war, ne?
Eher das Gegenteil eigentlich.
Eher das Gegenteil, damals war die Technik übertrieben nervig.
Ich gucke mir jetzt, wir gucken uns jetzt doch mal das Video von dem Network Dude an.
Weil ich bin mal gespannt, wie ähnlich das zu dem ist, was ich damals in meiner Ausbildung gemacht habe.
Wieso sehe ich die ganzen Emotes nicht? Weil du wahrscheinlich kein FFZ oder kein Better Twitch TV installiert hast.
Also du musst, dass du die Emotes siehst, musst du entweder das da installieren oder das da installieren.
Also entweder das da oder das da. Das ist eine Chrome-Aweiterung.
Also neben die normalen Twitch Emotes siehst du natürlich immer.
Und je nachdem welches du hast, musst du in diesem, das jeweils andere aktivieren.
Also in FFZ musst du Better Twitch TV Emotes aktivieren und in Better Twitch TV musst du FFZ Emotes aktivieren.
Ja ja, es reicht, es reicht, wenn du eins installierst. Also ich hab mittlerweile nur noch FFZ.
Und FFZ jetzt auch eine Funktion nachgerüstet hat, die ich besser fahre an Better Twitch TV.
Nämlich, dass man eine History hat. Also sprich, wenn man mit Pfeil nach oben, Pfeil nach unten im Chat drückt, hat man seine letzten Nachrichten quasi nochmal drin.
Nur die Twitch App? Nee, auf dem Handy geht es nicht. Es sei denn, du hast ein Android.
Auf Android gibt es custom, gibt es quasi von Drittanbietern Twitch Apps, die auch die Emotes können.
Die offizielle Twitch App kann das nicht. Auf Windows, ich wusste gar nicht, dass es auf Windows eine Twitch App gibt.
Da wahrscheinlich nicht, keine Ahnung.
Ja, aber du brauchst wie gesagt eins der beiden, Monkavin, eins der beiden Addons brauchst du.
Oder halt auf Android einen Custom Twitch Client.
Tjo. Und da siehst du die Emotes. Musst vielleicht in den Settings noch die GIF-Emotes einschalten, die sind standardmäßig aus.
Also die GIFs bewegen sich nicht hier. Coggers zum Beispiel bewegt sich standardmäßig nicht.
Aber sonst, ich kann es sich eh nur empfehlen, die Addons zu installieren. Da sind viele praktische Funktionen drin.
Zum Beispiel kannst du die Farben ein bisschen anpassen von Twitch, wenn dir die Standardfarben nicht gefallen.
Du kannst im Chat dich besser hervorheben lassen, wenn du angeschrieben wirst.
Du hast, wenn du Mod bist, bessere Modfunktionen. Du hast Uhrzeitanzeige vor den Chatnachrichten, wenn man das will.
Man kann die Chatnachrichten besser voneinander abheben lassen. Du hast Emote-Autovervollständigung.
Du hast eine History von deinem Chat. Also da kannst du alte Chatnachrichten einfach nochmal neu einfügen, ohne dass du die nochmal neu schreiben musst.
Du kannst die ganzen Overlays ausblenden lassen, die nervig sind.
Wenn beispielsweise es gibt ja Leute, die übertreiben es in ihrem Stream voll.
Die haben in ihrem Stream dann dieses Prime-Sub-Overlay und die haben dann das Bitte-Follow-Overlay.
Und die haben dann irgendwelche anderen Overlays und die kannst du einfach pauschal alle ausblenden lassen und sowas.
Also ich verwende die Addons wirklich gern. Ich könnte mir Twitch ohne gar nicht mehr angucken.
Deswegen nervt mich Twitch auf dem iPhone auch so ein bisschen.
Weil auf dem iPhone gibt es nur die offizielle Twitch-App, die die Hälfte der Sachen halt nicht unterstützt.
In FFZ, klar, du hast unten neben am Chat, hast du dir das Zahnrad. Und da klickst du drauf und sagst FFZ-Options.
Du guckst Twitch ohne. Also eher von dir hätte ich das jetzt nicht erwartet.
Hätte ich gedacht, du bist derjenige, der schon seit 3 Jahren mal mindestens Twitch-Addons hat.
Lohnt es sich eigentlich höher als 1080p zu streamen?
Nö. Nicht wirklich.
1080p ist, finde ich, ein guter Kompromiss aus, also auch schon 720p. Aber 1080p ist ein guter Kompromiss.
Du brauchst auch keine 60. Ich finde 1080p 48 ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Die Sachen sind flüssig. Das ist ein guter Kompromiss aus Rechenleistung, Bandbreite, die man braucht.
Naja, weil 60 FPS auch mehr Bandbreite brauchen würden.
Ich finde, das ist ein ganz guter Kompromiss.
Und 48 FPS sehen halt um ein vielfaches flüssiger aus in Games als 30. Das ist halt gerade der Witz.
Zwischen 48 und 60 werden, glaube ich, die meisten Leute in einem Stream, wenn man selbst spielt schon,
aber in einem Stream wahrscheinlich das Ganze nicht erkennen.
720p beim Programmieren ist blöd.
Wenn ich Programmieren streamen würde, generell wenn ich meinen Desktop streamen würde,
dann würde ich immer die Auflösung streamen, mit der ich auch auf dem Desktop unterwegs bin.
Also bin ich 1080p unterwegs, bin ich 1080p streamen und so weiter.
Weil ansonsten wird da Up und Down gescaled. Das sieht dann immer ein bisschen Mist aus, vor allem bei Schrift.
So, wir gucken uns jetzt mal hier den... den... ähm...
...ETZ Techniker an und ich bin mal gespannt, wie nah das an dem dran ist, was ich damals in meiner Ausbildung machen musste.
Aber davon abgesehen, das fängt schon mal falsch an. Ich bin nie mit dem Auto hingefahren.
Auto in 2010, lull. Nee, Schwachsinn 2010.
Äh, Auto in 2007, lull.
Ist ja schon ein bisschen her, ja.
Wo ich da gearbeitet hab.
Ich bin eigentlich ganz froh, dass ich nicht mehr in so einem... in so einem EZ-Betrieb, äh, EZ-Dienstleistungs... äh...
...Hosting, Gedönsladen arbeite.
Aber ich bin ja mehr oder weniger nach der Ausbildung auch direkt.
Oder ein, zwei Jahre, glaub ich, danach. Oder ein Jahr danach oder so bin ich gewechselt.
Nee, gut, das ist 20 Uhr abends.
Da würd ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr mit dem Fahrrad hinfahren.
Wobei ich sagen muss, auch...
...also auch, ähm, die paar Male, wo ich als Azubi gesagt hab, ja, ich bleib mal da...
...und auch nachts da war, da bin ich trotzdem im Zug hingefahren.
Weil, wie gesagt, Hauptbahnhof ist halt um die Ecke.
Und da fällt einem erstmal auf...
...wie ruhig es mittlerweile nachts Frankfurt im, äh, in der Bank, Bank-Ecke im Bahnhofsviertel ist.
Weil da ist keine Sau.
Da sind noch nicht mal Drogenabhängige.
Und da sind noch nicht mal irgendwelche Komet...
...da ist nichts, einfach nur...
Was ist es jetzt? Herz 93 macht ganz Ausrufezeichen beruflich.
Was ist jetzt? Herz 93 macht ganz Ausrufezeichen beruflich machen.
Da hab ich das versucht mal zu erklären.
Bereust du uns eigentlich, dass du nicht direkt ne Ausbildung als Anwendungsentwickler gemacht hast?
Nö.
Letztendlich ist es eh ziemlich, ziemlich egal, was du, was du da für ne Ausbildung gemacht hast.
Moncador.
Wo knallt er seine Tür so?
Ehh, NOC ist übrigens ein...
...Network Oper...
...Network Operation Center.
Ist das, heißt das.
Also im Prinzip, die Typen, die 24-7 da sitzen...
...First Level, Second Level und, und nachts Third Level Support machen.
Und, ähm, auch immer Zeit rumwetzen und so.
Hello.
Huge Motivated machen sie alle den Eindruck.
Aber ich kann euch aus allen Erfahrungen berichten, es ist keiner motiviert, wenn er da abends hingeht.
Und tagsüber auch nicht.
Generell überall da, wo 24-7 gearbeitet wird, ist eigentlich nie einer so richtig motiviert.
Das liegt aber auch hauptsächlich daran, weil die Leute schlicht und ergreifend müde sind.
Wenn du 24-7 in Schicht arbeiten musst, dann bist du, bist du tagsüber müde und bist immer müde.
Kennen das ja auch von den Leuten, die bei uns 24-7 arbeiten.
Das bleibt ja eigentlich gar nichts anderes übrig, außer müde zu sein.
Und dementsprechend, äh, dementsprechend wenig Motivation versprühen die Leute da auch.
Und man kann jetzt davon ausgehen, die faken schon eine gewisse, gewisse Motivation, also gewisser Motivations-Fake schon am Start.
Gerade weil ein Kamerateam dabei ist.
Normalerweise heugen die da wahrscheinlich auf halb acht und bewegen sich kaum.
Hi, my name's Raph.
Raph.
I'm the team leader here at Custodian Data Centers.
And you guys will be following me around for tonight's night shift.
Because we don't stop.
We go 24-7.
That includes nights.
Cool.
Ja, 24-7 sind leichte dabei, ja.
Oh, was hat er noch auf seinem Monitor?
Komm, wir versuchen das mal rauszukriegen.
Äh, okay.
Äh, die üblichen, die üblichen Verdächtigen aus Headset-Telefonen.
Okay, ein Funkgerät, das hatten wir nicht.
Hätten wir vielleicht, wäre vielleicht auch nicht, auch nicht schlecht gewesen.
Was ist denn das?
Ist das ein Zabbix oder ist das ein Nagios?
Schwierig, das ist schwierig zu erkennen.
Hat man die Monitore gesehen?
Die haben doch bestimmt eine Monitorwand.
Hat man die gesehen irgendwo?
Da.
Na, da erkennst du nix.
Okay, was hat er da drauf?
Es ist Windows.
Ich würd sagen, es ist Windows.
Es sieht aus wie Windows, oder?
Windows und im Hintergrund ist so was wie Outlook.
Das sieht nach Office, nach Office Ribbon Bar aus.
Und hier unten ist eine Windows-Taskleiste.
Und das hier im Vordergrund wird wahrscheinlich irgendein Messenger sein.
Safe Outlook, ja, denke ich auch.
Ich denke, das ist Windows mit Outlook und im Vordergrund irgendein Messenger.
Im Zweifelsfall wahrscheinlich Skype vor Büsnitz oder irgendwie so ein Crap.
Hi.
Ah ja, okay, hier sieht man es ja.
Äh, Kameragestellse.
Das ist ein Zappix, oder?
Ist das ein Zappix?
Erkennt man jetzt schlecht.
Erkennt man schlecht.
Was ist?
Zumindest wenn es ein Zappix ist, dann kein neuer Zappix.
Das ist irgendwie so ein Cacti oder sowas.
Man erkennt es auch schlecht.
Graphgedöns.
Noch mehr Graphgedöns.
Mal gucken, vielleicht sehen wir es irgendwann noch mal ein bisschen genauer.
Was ist ein Knock-Engine?
Das ist ein Network-Operation-Center.
Das sind die 24-7-Supportleute.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Es könnte ein Nagios, es könnte auch ein Zappix sein.
Das Bauchgefühl von der blauen Leiste oben, finde ich, sieht es eher aus wie ein Zappix als ein Nagios.
Monitoring-System.
Okay, jetzt sieht man es vielleicht ein bisschen besser.
Oder auch nicht.
Das ist...
Oder ganz was anderes?
Keine Ahnung, ist auch egal.
Sie leise, oder?
Was geht mit dem ab?
Ich lasse die Leute nie an meine Monitore dran.
Links unten ist Cactia, finde ich auch, das ist ähnliches, ja.
Also das da, das ganze Ding unten ist Cacti, das da.
Auch diese Karte.
Silex One US POC Twitch... Twitch Prime.
Hi IQ.
Dankeschön.
Was gibt das, wenn es fertig ist?
Verpackungs-ASMR.
Sobald ich diese Partie bekomme, könnt ihr mich folgen und sehen, was passiert.
So eine Oberfläche oben mit dem blauen?
Ja, ja, okay, es ist doch kein Zappix, es ist...
Es ist eindeutig...
Eindeutig ein Cacti, genau.
Das verwenden heute nur noch wenige.
Also ich habe zumindest keine Einschätzung nach, ja.
Ich meine, das ist jetzt nicht repräsentativ.
Aber viele Leute stehen heute auf so universal monitorigen Lösungen, die alles machen, sowas wie Zappix oder...
Aber Cacti ist vor allem, was Netzwerkeüberwachung angeht, immer noch ziemlich, ziemlich beliebt.
Andere Monitore sieht man nicht.
Das wirkt boring.
Die Leute, die dort arbeiten, die hoffen, dass es boring ist.
Weil sobald es nicht boring ist, musst du nachts sogar viel machen.
Also eigentlich hofft jeder drauf, dass es langweilig wird nachts.
Ah, diese Dinger, ja, nice, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Moment, da kann ich noch was zu erzählen.
Diese Dinger, diese Schleusen, die wiegen dich, dass du nichts drin lässt.
Da wirst du gewogen und wenn du einen Server reinträgst...
Also sprich, wenn du auf einmal irgendwie ein anderes Gewicht hast, ist merkwürdig.
Wenn du einen Server reinträgst, oder besser gesagt, wenn du halt den Trainer abstellst und wieder rausgehst,
dann geht meistens irgendwo was an oder zumindest kriegst du eine Info oder sowas.
Da kann man nichts essen, naja, gut, ein paar Kilo wird das nicht sein.
Ein Server wiegt ja auch schon mal 20, 30 Kilo.
Je nachdem, ich weiß nicht, wie die das gemacht haben, aber diese Schleusen, die ich kenne, die wiegen die Leute auch noch.
Die sehen halt genauso aus. Jetzt haben sie ihre Dieselmotoren.
Aber jeder hofft, dass es nie eintritt, ne?
Also das ist auch nur so, in der Theorie sind die Dinger in der Lage, alles zu betreiben, aber keiner will, dass das alles betreibt.
Wenn man es richtig macht, testet man das auch einmal im Jahr oder ab und zu mal.
Eine Menge Klimaanlagenstells.
Boah, krasse Zeitraffer hier.
Was ist das?
Was ist Spillkit?
Ist das so zum Aufsaugen oder was?
Ne.
Ach so, doch, ja.
Bindemittel, naja, gut, das ist sinnvoll, wenn das mal einer verschüttet oder wenn das kaputt ist.
Turbo Nautilus, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, Pock.
Übrigens heute, Leute, heute ist der letzte Tag, wo ihr Twitch Prime oder generell Twitch sammeln könnt, im ersten Monat, wo ich Partner bin.
Also wenn Any Primers noch im Chat sind, dann schlag zu.
Interaction macht im Jahr zweimal Black Building Tests, wo die alles auf Puffer fahren.
Bei Equinix hab ich noch nie gehört, dass die das testen.
Interaction ist auch bekannt.
Equinix ist auch bekannt.
Mein Nachbar arbeitet bei Equinix.
Und unser Rechenzentrum, also wir hatten bei Interaction ein paar Sachen stehen früher.
Ich bin mir jetzt gar nicht mehr sicher, wer Interaction...
War Interaction, waren das die vom Dezix?
Ja, genau.
Wo waren die, wo waren was, bei welchem Anbieter waren wir dann vorher?
Ach, keine Ahnung, ist auch egal.
Bist du noch StarCraft E-Spawn Institute? Ja, ab und zu guck ich noch mal.
Guckt er sich die UPS an?
Also das sind die Dinger, wenn da Strom ausfällt, mit Batterien drinnen, die halt das Ding weiter betreiben.
Die haben allerdings auch noch nicht eine wirklich lange Ladung.
In der Regel ist eine UPS auch hauptsächlich dafür da, um die Zeit zu überbrücken oder die Zeit sicher zu überbrücken, bis der Dieselmotor anläuft.
Die können natürlich meistens ein bisschen mehr.
Es gibt auch unterschiedliche UPS-Konzepte, aber die meisten UPS sind nicht darauf ausgelegt, dass sie jetzt irgendwie einen Tag...
Was bräuchst du da für riesen Akkus, ne, irgendwie einen Tag ein Rechenzentrum betreiben können.
Die UPS, die muss UPS machen, solange bis der Dieselmotor angelaufen ist.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was eine UPS ist. UPS ist mir klar, aber eine UPS, keine Ahnung.
Man hört schon, wie laut es da drinnen ist. UPS ist gleich USB, ja, ist das gleiche.
Der Buchhalter schreibt, danke für den Staubsauger-Flash und Root-Stream.
Werde den zu Rate ziehen, wenn ich meinen Roborock S5 am Wochenende flasche.
Kann ich nur empfehlen. Gibt jetzt ein neues Update für diese Software auf dem Staubsauger.
Es sind ein paar neue praktische Sachen dabei.
Es gibt ja für so Stromversorgung, gibt's ja verschiedene...
Was sagen wir so, zwei grundsätzlich verschiedene Systeme,
was du als Stromversorgung für sowas einsetzen kannst.
Es gibt so die normale Variante, wo einfach Batterien drin sind.
Also sprich, wenn der Strom ausfällt, werden die Server einfach über die Batterie versorgt,
bis der Strom wieder da ist. Strom kann aus der Leitung kommen, kann von einem Dieselmotor kommen,
das ist egal. Und die Oldschool-Variante, oder das, wo manche immer noch drauf schwören,
sind diese... Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die Dinger heißen.
Vielleicht weiß das jemand von euch, wie das heißt.
Ich nenne sie mal diese Analog-USV-Dinger, wo sie dann irgendein Riesengewicht haben,
was sich im Kreis dreht und was dann quasi, wenn der Strom ausfällt,
sich noch irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ein paar Sekunden weiter dreht,
um ein paar Sekunden Strom überbrücken zu können.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie diese Dinger heißen.
Hab ich mal gesehen, ist voll abgedreht, da hast du einen Raum im Keller,
da ist ein Schwung, da ist ein Gewicht im Prinzip drinne,
was schnell im Kreis, ich sag jetzt einfach mal, 150 Kilo oder so,
was da irgendwie im Kreis Schwung macht, so ein Speichel,
ja kann sein, genau sowas in der Richtung.
Was dann irgendwie, was dann halt im Kreis fliegt,
obwohl du auch nicht in die Wehen, in die Quere kommen willst,
kommst ja gar nicht rein, oder so ein Gewicht im Kreis rumfliegt
und wenn halt der Strom weg ist, dadurch, dass das Ding halt wirklich beschleunigt ist,
dann deutlich mehr, ich hab keine Ahnung, ganz ehrlich,
ich hab wirklich keine Ahnung, wie viel Gewicht wir da reden,
also ich bin null mit beschäftigt.
Ich hab's schon mal gesehen im Keller, da fliegt halt ein Gewicht im Kreis rum
und wenn der Strom halt ausfällt, dann bremst das Gewicht halt ab
und erzeugt damit halt mit der Masse, die sich im Kreis treten und ein bisschen weiter dreht,
erzeugt das Strom, dass es ein paar Sekunden ausreicht,
oder ich weiß nicht, wie lang es ausreicht, keine Ahnung, 10 Sekunden, 15 Sekunden oder so,
um die Sache noch mit Strom zu versorgen, bis der Dieselmotor angelaufen ist.
Das muss natürlich dann miteinander verbunden sein, also sprich, sobald der Strom weg ist
und das Ding, da hast du 10 Sekunden Zeit, also sprich, der Dieselmotor, der muss sofort hochdrehen,
also das ist nicht so nach dem Motto, ah ja, USV, die macht mal 20 Minuten, lass mal den Diesel starten,
nee, nee, das ist, Strom fällt aus, das Gewicht geht an, der Dieselmotor muss gleich vollem Puzzle Gas geben.
Es ist ein bisschen oldschool, ja, also ich bin auch der Ansicht Batterienbeste.
Ja, da ist er auch froh, dass es keine Probleme mit dem Strom gibt, das ist stressig, wenn was ist, ja,
also du bist auch meistens nachts alleine oder mit zwei Leuten da, also alleine, nee, das stimmt nicht,
alleine bist du eigentlich nirgendswo nachts, du bist eigentlich immer mit zwei Leuten da,
aber zumindest mit wenig Leuten bist du da und das heißt, du willst eigentlich nicht, dass nachts irgendwas passiert.
Vielleicht zeigt er mal ein bisschen was, was in den Racks drin ist.
Das erkennst du nicht, wenn du da drinnen bist, welcher Stock das ist, das sieht überall gleich aus.
Also weil du weißt das mit ein bisschen Erfahrung dann aber.
Ja, das stimmt, Glocks HD, das gibt es auch, aber du wirst es eigentlich, also in der Regel ist es so,
dass dort immer nur USBs verwendet werden, wo der Strom immer durch die USB geht und dann in die Racks.
Alter, das ist immer, das ist, und das ist jetzt nicht übertrieben, das Ding ist, das ist so laut, das ist so laut.
Das sind so ziemlich nur noch 15 Racks, die sehen eigentlich alle so aus, ja.
Ja, viel mehr gibt es dazu auch nicht, gibt es auch zu nichts.
Zumindest, wie das mit der Lüftung funktioniert, ist in der Regel so, also je nachdem wie es aufgeteilt ist,
für mich sieht das hier, ist der hier im Gang oder ist der in irgendeinem?
Das ist jetzt schwierig zu sehen, ob der im Gang steht oder ob der in so einem abgeschlossenen Abteil drinne steht.
Ich glaube, ich glaube mal, der steht im Gang.
Weil das ist halt so, dass die Dinger ansaugen und hinten rauspusten, wo die Klimaanlage ist.
Also du musst gucken, dass die Lüfter von allen Systemen auch in die richtige Richtung sind, ja.
Das ist meistens kein Problem, aber es gibt manche Hersteller, die machen es anders, weil, warum auch immer.
Dann hast du dann das Problem, dass du manche Geräte hast, wo du entweder den Lüfter drehen musst,
oder aber die du falsch herum einbauen musst.
...
Ich war ein bisschen leiser, das Sübel ist laut.
Ach, guck mal, was man eben gerade schön gesehen hat.
Das ist ziemlich ordentlich bei denen.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die auch nur die Sachen zeigen, die ordentlich sind.
Man sollte das ordentlich machen, keine Frage.
Aber, sag mal, so mit der Zeit wird es eigentlich überall immer ein bisschen unordentlicher.
Bei denen sieht das wirklich sehr ordentlich aus.
Es ist alles beschriftet.
Es ist alles beschriftet, das ist schon mal ganz cool.
Was auch viele nicht machen.
Die haben auch schön die Sachen hier durchgeführt nach hinten, also das sieht wirklich ordentlich aus.
Lüfter ASMR.
...
Ja, hier sieht es schon ein bisschen weniger ordentlich aus.
Aber gut, manche Racks haben halt viele Patch-Panels oder viele Switche drin.
Da brauchst du halt viele Kabel, geht nicht anders.
...
Aber man sieht es hier schon.
Hier ist nicht mehr alles beschriftet und hier ist auch ein bisschen kreuz und quer.
Aber das ist einfach der Lauf der Dinge mit der Zeit.
...
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keinen Plassen-Schimmer, was wir für ein Kühlsystem haben.
Es kühlt auf jeden Fall.
...
Florent, ich würde es auch nicht mehr machen wollen.
Ich würde es auch nicht mehr machen wollen.
Ich habe es ja nie richtig gemacht.
Ich war, wo ich Ausbildung gemacht habe, da war ich halt in so einem Laden, wo sowas gemacht wurde.
Aber als Natsumi machst du das ja eigentlich nicht 24-7, darfst du gar nicht.
...
Es ist aber ganz cool, dass man es gesehen hat.
An einem ganzen Tag oder das ganze Leben lang müsste ich es auch nicht machen.
...
Kühlsystem gleich kalte Luft, ja klar.
Dann dürfte es eigentlich nicht so laut sein bei der Klimaanlage jetzt.
...
Wahrscheinlich Vorschrift, dass man da Helm anzieht, weil...
Ja, das ist die Klimaanlage.
Ganz in Schächte sieht man eigentlich immer ganz gut daran, ob es eine Klimaanlage ist oder ein Diesel.
Das Bild hatten wir ja vorhin, bevor ich mir überlegt habe, ob das der Diesel-Generator oder die Klimaanlage ist.
Aber durch diese ganzen Räume, das muss eigentlich die Klimaanlage sein.
...
Pock!
Umi Pock!
...
Das habe ich auch immer als erstes gemacht morgens.
Als ich morgens auf die Arbeit gekommen bin, das erste, was ich immer gemacht habe, ist einmal einen Rundgang im RZ.
Dann hast du den Scheiß hinter dir.
Du konntest dich in die Ruhe vor den Rechner setzen und hattest deine Ruhe.
...
Eine Runde einmal RZ, Keller gucken.
Gut war.
Also einmal RZ und dann einmal in Keller.
Und gut war.
Zweimal in Keller, einmal ins RZ waren es, um genau zu sein.
...
Ah ja, lass uns zehn Minuten zugucken, wie er E-Mails readet.
Wahrscheinlich macht er ihn ja.
...
Wie lange bist du mit so einem Rundgang beschäftigt?
Der ist ja ganz davon ab, wie groß das RZ ist.
Kann man nicht sagen.
Also kommt ganz entscheidend davon an, wie groß das RZ ist, was man alles gucken soll und wie viel kaputt ist.
Wenn was kaputt ist, machst du es ja in der Regel.
Ich meine, es sei denn, es ist was ganz Triviales, dass irgendwie, keine Ahnung, einer vergessenen USB-Stick abzuziehen oder sowas.
Und selbst dann würde ich mir überlegen, ob ich den einfach so abziehe.
Machst du das ja nicht direkt vor Ort wieder ganz.
...
Du nimmst ja erst mal auf, dass irgendwo eine Warnleuchte, eine Warn-LED an ist, dass irgendwie eine Festplatte kaputt ist oder so.
Und dann musst du das erst mal in Ruhe dann in die Wege leiten, sobald du wieder drüben bist.
...
Support.
Da bin ich nicht der Richtige für.
Klein-Support, Leute.
Ich mag die Leute nicht, die anrufen.
Und die mögen mich nicht, wenn sie anrufen, weil sie das merken, dass ich sie nicht mag.
Deswegen kann ich keinen Klein-Support machen, das kriege ich nicht gebacken.
...
Ja, das ist 100 pro Outlook, Windows mit Outlook, Igitt.
Als, als Network Operations Dude, Windows, äh.
Ich krieg's ja mit.
Ich sitz ja, ich hab, ich, ich sitz ja, also, muss das, muss ja ein bisschen ausholen.
Ich hab, wenn man Ausrufezeichen in Beruf macht, erklär ich ja, was ich mache.
Aber ich sitze gar nicht bei dem Team, zu dem ich organisatorisch gehöre auf der Arbeit.
Ähm, ich sitze bei unserer Hotline, beziehungsweise bei unserem, äh, 24-7-Support im Büro.
Und da krieg ich die Storys immer mit, was da, was da für Leute teilweise anrufen.
Und das, da greifste dir echt an den Kopf, äh.
...
Ah, okay, das ist irgendeine, irgendeine Telefonsoftware, die er immer im Vordergrund hat.
Roger ruft jetzt an und sagt, man, ihr seid so ein Kackanbieter, bei euch funktioniert ja überhaupt nichts, ihr scheiß, ja.
Und regt sich erstmal auf.
Also wenn es ein realistischer Anruf wäre.
Nein, das stimmt nicht, das stimmt nicht.
Die meisten Leute sind, sind vollkommen in Ordnung.
Aber du hast halt manchmal schon ein paar Spasten dabei.
...
Warum sitzt du nicht bei deinem Team, hat das einen Grund, hat mehrere Gründe.
Ähm, ich hab's ja, ich hab's ja versucht mal zu erklären.
Ähm, dass ich mich darum kümmere, dass wir, äh, monatlich quasi immer, oder,
vermöglich monatlich, aber der Regel eigentlich immer monatlich, äh, ein Release von neuer Softwareversion, von neuer Config, von neuen Updates und alles Mögliche machen.
Und da passts arbeitsablauf-technisch besser dazu, wenn ich direkt dort sitze, wo eben die Wartungsarbeiten dann auch gemacht werden.
...
Und dazu kommt, dass ich dort lieber sitze, weil ich mit den Leuten besser kann.
Ja, Flow690, ein bisschen was ist da schon dran, ja.
Äh, aber, ähm, ich kann mit den Leuten da einfach besser.
...
Joa, das ist eigentlich der,
eigentlich der Hauptgrund, ja.
...
Wobei jetzt, bei uns hat's ja vor ner Weile, haben sie mal ein bisschen,
alle möglichen Führungskräfte durch Randomized, ähm, jetzt ist's eigentlich besser.
...
Jetzt, jetzt, ich hatte da, also, mit meinem alten Chef, der ging mir echt auf den Keks, ja, das wusste der auch, und, äh,
ich wusste auch, dass ihm das auf den Keks geht, dass es mir auf den Keks geht.
Das war voll planlos damals, ähm, vor, das ist schon eineinhalb Jahre oder zwei Jahre her, ähm,
es ist halt, es ist halt ziemlich doof, wenn du nen direkten Chef hast, der aus Prinzip die Sachen anders sehen muss.
Also der nicht irgendwie sagt, ah, okay, ähm, wir können das, wir können das nicht so machen, oder, oder, es wurde, wurde gesagt, es geht,
der ist aus Prinzip anders sieht, weil er es anders sehen will.
Das ist halt keine gute Basis, irgendwie, um was, um was zu machen, ja.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Das hat noch nicht funktioniert, das ging voll in die Hose.
Und der ist jetzt mittlerweile auch nicht mehr da.
Gucken wir mal weiter, was der Typ hier treibt.
Warst du in Frankfurt auf der Berufsschule? Ja, war ich.
Na dann, mach mal eine SSH Shell auf.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass ein ESX SSH Zugang hat.
Ein ESX SSH Zugang?
Ich bin aber echt ganz froh, so wie das mittlerweile auf der Arbeit ist,
weil ich bin verantwortlich für eben den Bereich, dass wir regelmäßige neue, neue, neue Versionen rausbringen
und muss mir um die Sache drum herum kümmern.
Und das ist mittlerweile halt auch insofern alles geklärt, dass da keiner irgendwie auf, auf Ideen kommen kann,
dass man das jetzt anders machen muss.
Weil man kann ja nicht sagen, ähm, Max und seine Vertretung sollen sich da drum kümmern,
aber die wollen sagen, wie sie es machen sollen. Das ergibt ja keinen Sinn.
Also entweder sagt man, die Leute sind dafür zuständig und dann lässt man sie es auch machen
und, und sorgt auch dafür, dass sie die Sachen entscheiden dürfen, die sie entscheiden dürfen, äh, entscheiden müssen, dürfen müssen.
Ähm, weil sonst kann das ja nicht funktionieren.
Deswegen bin ich da mittlerweile eigentlich wirklich zufrieden, wie das auf der Arbeit funktioniert.
Aber das funktioniert ja auch. Ich glaube, wir haben noch nicht einmal, wir sind jetzt bei Versionen,
lass mal überlegen, was kommt als nächstes.
Vom vier...
Ja, wir sind quasi bei Versionen, ich sag mal, 64.
Ähm, bei eins hat es angefangen.
So, und da kann man sich überlegen, wenn wir bei 64 sind, wir machen einmal im Monat gibt es eine neue Version.
Bei 64, ähm, haben wir schon, wir machen das elfmal.
So, mach ich das seit fünf, fünfeinhalb Jahre ungefähr.
Und fünfeinhalb Jahre, seit ich mich drum kümmere, dass wir unsere Releases zeitmäßig passend rauskriegen,
hatten wir noch nicht ein Release, was wirklich kaputt war, also großartig.
Ja, ich mach's nur elfmal im Monat.
Ich hab mir das so überlegt, dass im Dezember bin ich nicht da und auch sonst kaum einer da und auch kaum Programmierer,
da gibt's eh nix Neues, deswegen machen wir im Dezember immer nix.
Es war noch nicht eine Version, seit ich das mache, richtig im Arsch.
Ich mein, klar, es gab immer mal die ein oder anderen Bugs.
Ähm, aber so schlecht kann's ja nicht funktionieren.
Ich hab eine Vertretung, ja.
Da musste ich auch lange dafür rumnerven.
Ähm, ich hab immer wieder gesagt, Jungs, wenn ich nicht da bin, mercht keiner irgendwelche Sachen,
wenn ich nicht da bin, guckt sich keiner an, was irgendwie aufgemacht wurde.
Ähm, es sorgt, es guckt sich keiner an, die Fehlerreports, die irgendwie kommen, es passiert nichts, wenn ich nicht da bin.
Das kann nicht den Zweck der Sache sein.
Außerdem bin ich immer mal, bin ich den ganzen Dezember nicht da oder vielleicht bin ich auch mal krank,
da kann ich sein, dass dann nichts passiert.
Ich mein, es könnte ja mal sein, dass es wirklich wichtige Hotfixes braucht, weil wirklich mal was komplett im Arsch ist.
Meistens, wenn wir Sachen hotfixen, sind die nicht großartig im Arsch,
sondern die funktionieren immer noch halbwegs und es sieht nur so aus, als gehen sie demnächst kaputt.
Ähm, und ja, und seit, seit ungefähr...
So ungefähr eineinhalb Jahren habe ich jetzt tatsächlich eine Vertretung.
Die haben sie extra geholt dafür.
Ja.
Ähm...
Ist die jetzt eigentlich schon mal aufs Klo?
Aber wir gucken das jetzt noch kurz fertig.
Was für eine Software ist das?
Also wir haben, wir haben ziemlich, ziemlich viel Verschiedenes.
Ähm, die hauptsächliche Sache ist, wie erkläre ich denn das am besten jetzt?
Also wir haben viel Java gedürnt.
Ähm, aber das ist eigentlich nicht so, nicht so das...
Wie erkläre ich das jetzt am besten?
Du hast, also mal angenommen, irgendjemand hat was Neues, ähm, Java-technisches programmiert.
Ähm, und die sagen, keine Ahnung, sie haben irgendwie marketingmäßig schon versprochen,
dass die neue, dass das irgendwie innerhalb, in zwei Wochen, in zwei Wochen oder so muss das,
oder in einem Monat oder so muss das da sein.
Das ist eh mal, das ist immer meine Lieblingssache, wenn Sachen quasi unbedingt jetzt gemacht werden müssen,
nicht weil sie dran sind, sondern weil irgendjemand vom Marketing versprochen hat,
dass es diese Funktion demnächst gibt.
Und, ähm, da muss man gucken, dass alles zueinander passt, also sprich, die Softwareversion muss passen.
Gut, mit den Leuten, die das Java-mäßig programmieren, habe ich jetzt relativ wenig zu tun.
Du musst gucken, dass die passenden Libraries auf dem Betriebssystem drauf sind.
Du musst gucken, dass, was weiß ich, ähm, im Zweifelsfall die Version von irgendeiner Library stimmt,
oder dass irgendwie eine Config-Datei zum passenden Zeitpunkt da ist.
Und das muss, das ist halt ein Gesamtsystem, was du in einem Config-Management-System irgendwie abbilden musst,
dass das reproduzierbar ist, also sprich, wenn dir der Server abkackt,
dass du den Kram auch genauso funktionieren wie du hinstellen könntest,
dass du nachgucken kannst, wann Änderungen drin sind und dass die Sachen zueinander passen.
Also sprich, Configs, Pakete, ähm, Paketversionen, Config-Einträge und Softwareversionen.
Und quasi dieses Gesamtpaket, da kümmere ich mich rum.
Ja, Flo96, habe ich das nicht, habe ich das nicht, äh, bei Ausrufezeichen berufausführlich erklärt?
Ansonsten kann ich noch mal probieren zu erzählen.
Ja, ja, das, das, äh, ja, das, das ist wirklich nervig, ja, da stehe ich recht.
Das ist, das ist wirklich ätzend, also, das kommt auch öfters vor, dass, ähm, keine Ahnung,
es gibt irgendwie ein Ticket oder irgendwie, irgendwie einer aus dem Team soll sich drum kümmern, dass,
keine Ahnung, dass irgendwie eine neue, sagen wir einfach mal, eine neue, eine neue Domain eingerichtet wird,
oder, nee, Domain ist blöd, das ist nicht bei uns, ähm, keine Ahnung,
aber dass, dass irgendwie irgendwas Neues bereitgestellt wird,
weil das Marketing versprochen hat, dass es irgendwie eine neue, eine neues Feature gibt innerhalb von zwei Wochen.
Und das fällt ihnen dann halt nicht etwa ein, quasi zwei Monate, als es schon in der Planungsphase ist,
sondern das fällt ihnen dann meistens ein fünf Tage, bevor es eingeführt werden muss,
weil man konnte es ja noch nicht testen und jetzt muss das ganz furchtbar schnell und, und an allem vorbei gemacht werden.
Das sind auch die Sachen, die gehen mir immer am meisten auf den...
Sitz dein Unternehmen in Frankfurt.
Ja.
Hier sind, äh, mittendrinne in Frankfurt.
Remote Hands, das finde ich ist immer noch die schönste, die schönste Umschreibung für
wir laufen ins RZ und klicken für jemand anderen was.
Remote Hands.
Wir haben das früher Turnschuhadministrator genannt.
Aber die schönere Bezeichnung ist Remote Hands.
Hattest du schon mal Kontakt zu Hardware Engineering?
Dass ich wüsste.
Also außer, dass ich ein bisschen mit ESP-Microcontrollern herum gewurstet habe und auf dem Predboard ein paar Dinge herumgesteckt habe,
hält sich das sehr in Grenzen.
Der ESX hat echt den SSH drin?
In Wirklichkeit hat er halt überhaupt keinen Bock da drauf.
Der hat überhaupt keinen Bock drauf jetzt aufzustehen darüber zu laufen.
Überhaupt nicht.
Er muss jetzt so tun, weil das Kamerateam dabei ist, dass er es geil findet, aber er findet es nicht geil.
So.
Jetzt erstmal schön, äh, ja genau.
Gibt es auch zwei Varianten von.
Die einfachere Variante ist so ein Wagen mit Monitor und Tastatur.
Es gibt auch noch die Variante, dass du für KVM-Switch so Kabel liegen hast, die du dann anstöpselst und du hast in so einem extra Raum dann den Monitor dafür.
Ich habe es persönlich auch lieber gemacht mit dem Monitor-Wagen als über die KVM-Switches.
Einfach weil die KVM-Switches nicht so zuverlässig funktionieren wie ein Monitor-Wagen.
Bei KVM-Switches hast du oftmals das Problem gehabt, zumindest mit den KVM-Switches, die wir hatten.
Das ging dann halt, ähm, vor dem Rack, ähm, vor dem Kabel.
Die KVM-Switches, die wir hatten.
Das ging dann halt, ähm, vor dem Rack, durch die Wand, durch die Decke, durch den Boden, äh, sonst wie rum, bis es dann in dem kleinen, in dem kleinen Mini-Raum, wo halt die KVM-Geschichten gestanden haben, rausgekommen sind.
Ähm, und da ging es oftmals nicht.
Das war ätzend.
Und mit einem Monitor, mit einem Monitor-Wagen war eigentlich immer am besten angestöpselt, dann Taste gedrückt und, äh, ist übrigens auch die Zeit, wo ich mir angewöhnt habe,
immer, immer Control zu drücken, um den Bildschirm einzuschalten, weil man nie weiß, was eigentlich gerade im Hintergrund läuft.
Und wenn man jetzt eine Taste drückt, Control, ich kenne keine Software, die auf Control, einfach Control, ohne irgendwas zu drücken, allergisch reagiert.
Deswegen habe ich immer Control gedrückt, um die, quasi den Monitor einschalten zu lassen, nachdem das angestöpselt hat.
Du musst jetzt irgendeine Taste drücken zum Einschalten.
Und, ähm, weil wenn du beispielsweise, keine Ahnung, wenn du Leertaste gedrückt hast, Enter, F1, irgendwas, hat es im Zweifelsfall was gemacht im Hintergrund, wo es angeschlossen war.
Und das wolltest du nicht.
Deswegen habe ich mir das für die Zeit, wo ich mir angewöhnt habe, mit Control den Bildschirm einzuschalten.
Ja, das ist eindeutig ESX.
ESX sieht immer so hässlich aus.
Also die Farbwahl.
Jetzt hat er sein Passwort, jetzt könnte er ihn erstmal schön skamasen.
Aber macht er nicht, weil sonst wird er wahrscheinlich rausgeschmisst.
In Wirklichkeit hofft er, dass der Typ seinen Kram selbst gefixt kriegt, dass er nicht nochmal rüberlaufen muss.
Was ist OTDR? Data? Nee.
OTDR? Optik? Optik?
Was ist OTDR? Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Optical Time Domain Reflect Domain.
Huge Brain.
Okay, es ist im Endeffekt ein Testgerät, wahrscheinlich für Glasfaserkabel.
Super motivierter Gesichtsausdruck.
Leute, ich habe es am Anfang gesagt, die Leute, die 24-7 arbeiten, die haben permanent so einen Gesichtsausdruck, einfach weil du müde bist.
Du bist immer müde. Du bist tagsüber müde, du bist mittags müde, meistens ist es ja so.
Also es gibt die ganzen Hardcore-Ausbeutungs-24-7-Betriebe, die machen 12-Stunden-Schichten.
420 ist es, genau.
Da bist du im Arsch und da gibt es ein bisschen wenige Ausbeutungsbetriebe, die machen Frühschicht, Spätschicht, Nachtschicht.
Plus eventuell ein bisschen Übergangsphase.
Wahrscheinlich ist das hier der übelste Ausbeutungsladen, der Zwölverschichten macht.
Das stimmt. Das stimmt. Das stimmt.
Kupferkabel kannst du viel einfacher testen als Glasfaserkabel.
Ist doch irgendwie logisch.
Ja, das ist so ein Ding, da kann man gucken.
Also ich vermute mal, dass das so ein Tester ist.
Da kann man gucken, wo die Kabel laufen.
Du lässt es quasi blinken und du siehst auf der anderen Seite, wo es blinkt halt.
Kann man dir ja anders erklären.
Ja, genau.
Übrigens würde ich euch generell nicht empfehlen, in Glasfaserkabel rein zu gucken.
Bei den meisten Sachen ist es nicht schlimm.
Es gibt aber ein paar Übertragungs-Laser-Übertragungs-Sachen, das ist für die Augen nicht gut, wenn man es ins Auge kriegt.
Also ich würde zum Testen nicht in Glasfaserkabel reingucken.
Am besten ist, du nimmst ein Stück Papier und lässt es drauf leuchten.
Ja gut, das ist halt ein Testgerät, das testet.
Was soll das machen? Das testet halt.
Max-Elektronik, das ist natürlich huge brain.
Wenn man Augenschäden bekommt, weiß man, dass es an ist.
Das ist mal next level.
Das nenne ich mal Einsatz, Arbeits-Einsatz.
Erstmal das Auge frittieren lassen vom Laser, um zu gucken, ob das Netzwerk richtig angeschlossen ist.
Ich bin froh, dass die Glasfaserkabel mittlerweile fast alle diesen kleinen Anschluss haben.
Also generell Anschluss bei Glasfaserkabel ist übelster Wildwuchs.
Im Gegensatz zu den meisten Netzwerkkabel, die einfach einen LH-45-Stecker haben,
oder eben einen SFP-Plus-Stecker oder einen SFP-Stecker für Netzwerkzeuge,
haben generell alle möglichen Sahngeschichten oder Glasfasern ganz viele verschiedene Anschlüsse.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die Dinge heißen, aber das sind die kleinen Normalen, die sich heute verbreitet sind.
Es gibt da noch die großen weißen Viereckigen und was auch immer.
Davon fragen, wie alt du bist, 35.
100, genau, 1300 Nanometer, 850 Nanometer, sieht man doch eigentlich so offensichtlich.
Einfach mal reingucken, einfach mal in das Kabel reingucken, da siehst du sofort, ah klar, 1300 Nanometer und 850 Nanometer.
Easy as fuck.
Und nix wie heim.
So redet keiner miteinander bei der Schichtübergabe.
Sie reden nur so miteinander, weil irgendwo ein Kamerateam dabei ist.
In Wirklichkeit geht das anders. Der Typ kommt rein und fragt, ey, Alter, bist du noch wach?
Der andere sagt, so eine kacke, endlich kann ich heim. So in der Richtung.
Das wäre so der realistischere Talk und nicht so dieses Fake-Professionelle.
Oder man redet gar nicht, ja, das kann auch sein.
Aber gut, da ist ja ein Kamerateam dabei, da können die ja nicht irgendwie, da muss das seriös wirken.
Oh, ausloggen, zack.
Merkt euch eins, immer Bildschirm locken, wenn ihr vom Arbeitsplatz weggeht.
Weil es gibt lustige Leute, die an eurem Rechner Zeugs machen.
Und das sind Leute, das sind Menschen, die mir ultra auf den Sack gehen.
Man muss nicht alles ausnutzen, nur weil einer mal was vergessen hat.
Da würde ich auch, ohne Scheiß, wenn mittlerweile irgendjemand auf die Idee kommen würde, wenn ich vergessen sollte.
Ich sperre mein Rechner immer.
Aber sollte ich ihn mal nicht sperren und irgendjemand kommt auf die Idee, in meinem Namen irgendwelche Einträge zu machen oder E-Mails verschicken,
da würde ich heute keinen Spaß mehr verstehen.
Da würde ich direkt zum Chef gehen und direkt, wenn die nichts machen, direkt zum Betriebsrat oder irgendwas.
Weil das sind Leute, die mir mega auf den Sack gehen.
Also solange das sich in Grenzen hält, ist es okay.
Ja, wenn einer jetzt meinen Desktop-Hintergrund ändert oder da irgendwas draufschreibt, genau, so was.
Wenn irgendjemand schreibt, ich lade euch alle zu Mittagessen ein, da wird ich mich instant beschwenken.
Da verstehe ich mittlerweile keinen Spaß mehr.
Wenn einer meinen Desktop-Hintergrund ändert oder irgendjemand einen Pop-Up einrichtet, so ist es ja noch irgendwie ganz lustig.
Das sind so Sachen, die würde ich vielleicht auch noch mitmachen.
Aber sobald einer irgendwelche E-Mails verschickt in meinem Namen oder irgendwo Einträge machte, so kannst du voll vergessen.
Anzeige ist raus, Alter, Abmahnung ist raus.
Ja, er freut sich schon richtig, dass er...
Der hat jetzt voll die Arschkarte, ne?
Der geht jetzt heim um 8 Uhr morgens, der muss jetzt erstmal heim, muss wahrscheinlich noch was machen,
dann muss er pennen, kann nicht richtig pennen, weil es tagsüber ist.
Und wenn er aufwacht, kann er nichts machen und muss fast schon wieder direkt auf die Arbeit.
Übelst, übelst für den Arsch.
Na, Saito, das finde ich nicht richtig.
Es kann immer mal irgendjemand was verkacken und das muss man nicht gleich ausnutzen.
Ähm, moindingsbums.
I want to give this video a thumbs up, subscribe, give me a comment, give me two comments and I'll see you around.
Achso, ich bin nicht eingeloggt.
Gebt jemanden ein Thumb up.
Brauchen wir mal nicht so sein.
Der wird jetzt erstmal gewogen und festgestellt, er wiegt zu viel, da haben wir ihn mal rein.
Moin, Bruddes.
Moin, Dennis.
Have a good night.
Bye.
Thank you.
Link!
Give him a like.
Alter, die Musik.
Aber das hat wirklich, finde ich, ganz gut wiedergespiegelt, wie es so ist.
Ja, fand ich, fand ich cool gemacht.
Das war auch nicht, es war auch kein, ich meine, es ist ein Marketingvideo von Custodian Datacenters,
wer auch, was auch immer das für Dudes sind, keine Ahnung.
Ähm, aber das war jetzt nicht so ein übertriebenes Werbevideo, wo sie, wo sie komplett eskaliert sind,
wie happy sie sind, da zu arbeiten oder wie, wie toll das Team ist oder wie toll alles auf der Welt ist,
wenn man bei Custodian arbeitet.
Das war ein realistisches Video, ja.
Kann man nichts sagen.
Das finde ich gut.
Pepehands Wetter.
Bei uns ist richtig gutes Wetter.
Blauer Himmel, Sonne scheint.
IPS Wetter.
Besser als von meiner Klitsche, das ist Cringe Overload.
Oh, wollen wir uns das mal angucken?
Oder willst du anonym, anonym bleiben?
Bevor ich off gehe, noch mal so ein ordentliches Cringe Werbevideo, wäre doch nicht verkehrt.
Ach so, im Video, im Video ist, im Video ist Deprivetter, ja, das stimmt.
Aber das ist auch London oder England irgendwo gewesen.
Da ist das immer so.
Wenn ich bei Find Exec mehrere Commands hintereinander pipen,
pipen, was benutze ich da am besten?
X-Args?
Oder was meinste?
Du kannst mit Find...
Ach ne, ah, du meinst im, du meinst im Exec, äh, einfach Single Quotes machen und, und pipen.
Kein Problem.
Einfach alles in Single Quotes setzen.
Einfach in Single Quotes setzen.
Oder du verwendest X-Args und gar kein Exec von Find, kannst du auch machen.
Und direkt dein Exec immer mit einem Semikolon abschließen.
Das funktioniert doch nicht, wenn meine Dateinamen Single Quotes...
Deine Dateinamen beinhalten Single Quotes.
Okay, ähm...
Wenn deine Dateinamen Single Quotes enthalten, dann sollte das trotzdem funktionieren.
Wenn nicht, würde ich mit X-Args machen.
Mit X-Args kannst du da eigentlich nichts großartig verkehrt machen.
Dateinamen die Single Quotes enthalten.
Ne, du kannst sie nicht mit Backslash escapen, weil, ähm, was sind Single Quotes?
Das da.
Das sind Double Quotes und das sind Single Quotes.
Wir machen jetzt mal Minox an, wir gucken uns jetzt an, wie das mit Find funktioniert.
Ich wusste, ich glaube ich hatte in letzter Zeit nie Dateinamen Single Quotes.
Okay, ne, ne.
Ah, okay, aber Moment.
OMG, ins Moment probieren wir das gleich mal aus.
Ja, okay, okay.
Zu.
Also, Streamtest machen wir mal an Ordner.
So, und da legen wir jetzt mal ein paar Dateien an.
Ich muss erst mal überlegen, wie ich überhaupt Dateien anlege, mit Single Quotes drinne.
Okay, eins, Punkt, lup.
Da machen wir jetzt irgendwie Single Quotes rein. Geht das überhaupt?
Tatsächlich. Jetzt haben wir Dateien mit Single Quotes.
Ha, krass.
Okay, wir legen mal ein paar Dateien an.
Äh, ein paar Dateien an mit Single Quotes drinne.
So, wir haben ein paar Dateien mit Single Quotes.
Wir haben 100 Dateien mit Single Quotes.
So, und jetzt finden wir die Dateien.
Oder, warte mal, du hast deinen Befehl gepostet, ne?
Name.
Ich nehme mal den Befehl von dir.
Ich nehme mal deinen Befehl.
Gut, Max Depth können wir uns sparen.
Exec.
Okay, na gut, das muss ich ein bisschen anpassen.
Ich will einfach nur Sternchen blub, ne?
Moment.
Gerade irgendwie bin zu durf dafür.
Ha, sehr schön.
Äh, warum funktioniert das mit Single Quotes nicht?
Ups.
Ah, okay, passt.
Punkt Sternchen ist übrigens da, was anderes.
Ähm.
Nee, das ist doch egal, wo ich die Single Quotes habe.
Oder?
Ist doch wurscht, wo ich die Single Quotes habe.
Hauptsache, es funktioniert mit Single Quotes.
Ähm, so, und jetzt willst du was machen?
Exec.
Exec, Echo, irgendwie so ging das doch.
Nee, fuck.
Moment, wie ging das jetzt noch mal?
Exec?
Warte.
Ging das nicht mit geschweiften Klammern,
wo man Parameter einsetzen sollte?
Ach nee, man muss noch abschließen mit, ähm,
irgendwie Kolon, ne?
Da sieht man mal, was für ein Kacknup bin.
Ähm, ich dachte, das ging so,
dass man an der Stelle einsetzen kann.
Hm.
War ich verkehrt?
Machen wir hier Cat.
Weil das hier brauchen wir eigentlich gar nicht dafür.
Missing Argument?
Was genau ist das Problem?
Das ist doch so eigentlich richtig.
Ich mein, wir können auch irgendwie so Type F sagen.
Also von der Idee her würde ich sagen, das ist so richtig.
Ist das auch das gleiche Problem, was du hast?
Ach, brauche ich hinten sowas?
Ah.
Hab ich nicht eben noch gesagt, immer mit Semikolon abschließen
und machs jetzt selber nicht?
Ich hab doch vor 5 Minuten noch gesagt,
immer mit Semikolon abschließen.
Ja, aber es funktioniert doch.
Also zumindest sagt er, dass Körner gefallen.
Was hat der Dude jetzt für Schmerzen?
Ich muss hier gerade mal einen neuen Ordner machen und gucken,
wie das ohne Optis wirklich an den Single-Quotes-Sachen liegt.
Ähm.
Detach.
So.
Exec.
Aber das müsste doch eigentlich auch so funktionieren.
Ich mein, wenn das denn so kompliziert war, das doch gar nicht.
Das, das, das ging doch anders.
Das ging doch irgendwie.
Je nachdem, wie man, wie man einen Semikolon gemacht hat,
hat er das doch unterschiedlich ausgeführt.
Entweder irgendwie eins pro Zeile oder so weit, wie es maximal geht.
Aber wir machen das jetzt.
Easy.
Okay, da muss, da muss wirklich ein Semikolon am Ende sein.
Ah ja, Konzentration.
Also man muss, man muss das machen.
Hä?
Ich steh grad voll am Schlauch, wo ist denn das Problem?
Also der sollte das doch jetzt eigentlich schlicht und ergreifend einfach ausgeben.
Kommt mir grad wieder übelste Linux-Kackdruck vor.
Das Echo nicht in den Quotes, warum nicht?
Tatsächlich.
Das kann man doch Quoten, das Zeug.
Ach.
Oh, ich weiß, was ich verkehrt gemacht hab.
Wenn du den Kram quotest, der versucht, ah, okay, jetzt hab ich's gecheckt,
der versucht, wenn du das so reinschreibst, versucht er ein Kommando auszuführen,
was Echo, Dateinahme heißt.
Das kann natürlich nicht funktionieren.
Wie das Ganze funktionieren würde, ist, jetzt hab ich's jetzt weiß ich noch,
was ich verkehrt gemacht hab, wie das Ganze funktionieren würde,
ist, wenn du sagst, hier bash, bash minus C, das funktioniert.
Jetzt weiß ich alles, was ich vergessen hab.
Dachte auch schon, ich verstehe die Welt nicht mehr.
Genau.
Du kannst ihm einfach sagen, exec bash und nimm das als Parameter hintendran.
Ja, dann funktioniert's.
Wollt grad sagen, the fuck, was ist hier verkehrt?
Genau, ja, jetzt ergibt das nämlich auch irgendwie Sinn.
Okay, jetzt können wir mal zurückgehen in das andere mit.
Interessant.
So, einfach ohne machen.
Ach so, ich bin im Falle.
Nee, doch, ich bin richtig.
Doch, das funktioniert.
So, okay, was, was probierst du jetzt auszuführen, was nicht geht?
OMG, it's mo, was genau, wo, also wo, wo kackt's jetzt ab?
Also was, was, was muss ich jetzt machen, dass es kaputt geht?
Du kannst hier irgendwie pipen oder so.
Das muss man nämlich quaten, wenn man pipen will, relativ sicher.
Ich meine, gut, du kannst die Pipe wahrscheinlich es capen oder so.
Mach mal mal.
Okay, du kannst, du kannst die Pipe es capen, aber das ist jetzt auch nicht Sinn und Zweck der Übung.
Ach so.
Also ich würd's quaten, ehrlich gesagt.
Was besser ist, oder?
Also was haben wir hier zur Auswahl?
Mal gucken, wo der Unterschied ist.
Das ist gleich, ne?
Ach, dein exactier.
Seht, okay, du willst irgendwie das Binary Zeug ersetzen.
Das fun, das fun, das funktioniert auch so.
Also was das hier, also was das hier macht, soweit ich das sehe, ist,
der gibt dir den Inhalt von den Dateien aus und replace da drin halt das hier.
Und am Ende machst du einen Hashwert über die gesamte Ausgabe.
Also du machst keinen Hashwert über jede einzelne Zeile, oder?
Seh ich das richtig?
Das ist doch am Ende, das Pipe zählt nicht mehr zu dem Befehl dazu.
Das kommt am Ende, der macht erst mal, der macht erst mal das komplette Find
und danach macht er ein Hashwert drüber, also quasi sowas hier.
Also so, wie wenn ich das jetzt irgendwie ausgebe.
So und dann irgendwie MD5 Summe oder so dahinter mache.
Das ist jetzt quasi, genau, das ist über alles.
So und dann oder Name like Bash.
So würde das für jede Datei machen.
Also nein, nicht für jede Datei.
So würde das für jeden Durchlauf von Find machen.
Also so wie ich das sehe, machen die zwei Sachen komplett unterschiedliche Dinger.
Hier machst du ein Seht über alle Dateien
oder über so viele Dateien wie maximal in der Argumentliste erlaubt sind.
Ansonsten würde Find eine zweite Sache ausführen.
Und dann machst du ein Hashwert über die komplette Ausgabe.
Und hier quasi pro Durchlauf von Find, weil das ja zum Kommando dazugehört.
Also das zweite finde ich ist die schönere Variante.
Und das zweite funktioniert nicht mit Dateien mit Single Quartz.
Ok, das probieren wir jetzt nochmal aus.
Ach stimmt, nur mit Plus.
Das sind so die Besonderheiten von.
Letzteres geht bei Double Quartz nicht.
Also so die Besonderheit von Find, worüber ich auch jedes Mal nachgucken muss.
Genau, wenn du Plus machst, verketter das so viel wie geht.
Und ansonsten macht er immer eins pro Zeile.
Naja.
Das letzte funktioniert bei Double Quartz nicht, wahrscheinlich wegen dem Kram.
Deswegen sackt das in Basch sowas zu machen.
Escape Hell in Basch.
Ganz ehrlich, wahrscheinlich würde ich mir dafür ein Ruby Ding basteln.
So Ruby-Zweizeiler oder so, aber das muss auch damit funktionieren.
So, wir machen mal kurz das Seed weg.
Was macht denn Minus C überhaupt?
Ach so, das liest quasi eine Zeile mit Files ein, um sie dann zu checken.
Schwerzen.
Naja, das würde ich, also Laufzeit zwischen Pius und Ruby und Basch, würde ich, auch wenn Pius und Ruby nicht die schnellsten sind, würde ich immer noch sagen, schneller als Basch.
Dürfte das sein in der Stelle.
Vor allem schneller als Basch, wenn du viele Pipes verwendest, wo Textzeuge hin und her kopiert wird.
Aber ich bin jetzt ehrlich gesagt auch ein bisschen verwirrt, warum das nicht funktioniert.
Wenn da Quartz drin sind.
Das kriegen wir aber raus.
Ja, der hat Schmerzen, wenn Quartz da drin ist.
Der hat Schmerzen, wenn Quartz da drin ist.
Ach so, die Geschwindigkeit vom Hatch.
Ja, das könnte tatsächlich sein, dass die Python-Implementierung ein bisschen langsamer ist.
Aber im Zweifelsfall immer noch das Command direkt aufrufen kannst, auch aus Python raus.
Da bin ich mir nicht sicher, was da schneller langsam ist.
Aber was hat der für Schmerzen?
Das ist echt eine interessante Sache hier mit Files mit Single Quartz drin.
Was sagt denn Stack Overflow dazu?
Find exact Single Quartz in Filename.
Stack Overflow, im Zweifelsfall immer Stack Overflow.
Print 0 ist, ich glaube Newline ersetzen durch 0.
Was man natürlich machen könnte, so was machen.
Deswegen hattest du auch die Dateinamen gequartet vorhin.
Sonst nicht funktioniert.
Was versuchst du gerade?
Es hat gerade einer im Chat gefragt, was waren denn mal Hashwerte von Files, die Single Quartz enthalten.
Und was ist jetzt da?
Ich hab das noch nie verstanden, wie macht man das?
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung, was man mit Minus C macht, ehrlich gesagt.
Ach, das sind Files, wo Checksum drinstehen.
Ich glaube, jetzt habe ich kapiert, was du machen willst.
Du hast Files, in denen ganz viele Checksum drinstehen.
Und du willst quasi überprüfen, ob die Checksum von den Dateien noch stimmen.
Da fällt mir jetzt auch keine perfekte Lösung für ein.
Außer, dass ich es wahrscheinlich nicht in Bash machen würde.
Kann man einfach die Single Quartz wegmachen dafür?
Nee, kannst du nicht, weil dann stimmen die Dateinamen ja nicht.
Jetzt habe ich es verstanden.
Du machst mit dem Seed quasi diese Encoding-Geschiss vorne weg, weil es dann rumspackt.
Und das hier kackt ab, wenn du Dateinamen mit Double Quartz drin hast.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass es einen großartigen Unterschied in der Laufzeit macht, ehrlich gesagt.
Ob du es jetzt mit Python machst, mit Ruby oder mit Bash in dem Fall.
Du kannst im Zweifelsfall einfach auch die Char512-Geschichte aufrufen von Python aus.
Allerdings würde ich es einfach mal in Python ausprobieren, weil ich gehe mal davon aus,
dass wahrscheinlich die Python-Krypto-Funktionen ganz normal OpenSSL verwenden werden.
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal. So wie das hier eventuell unter der Haube auch.
Das weiß ich nicht. Ich würde es mal ausprobieren.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das Standard Python-Char256 oder Char512 großartig langsam ist.
Wahrscheinlich ist das einfach nur ein Rapper für OpenSSL.
Ja. Ich muss sagen, doch. Blablabla.
Genau. Also das benutzt OpenSSL. Und wenn das OpenSSL benutzt, ist das schnell.
Ja, sowas ist in Bash wirklich eklig. So Escape-Geschiss.
Ich habe mal was probiert zu machen, wo du per SSH ein alias-File rüberkopiert hast,
dass du dann quasi deine eigenen Alias auf dem Server hast.
Und da musstest du quasi 50-mal es capen, dass der Kram richtig funktioniert.
Das ist richtig massiv eklig in Bash.
Wollen wir das Ganze mal in PowerShell machen? Nee. Wollen wir nicht.
Wobei ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass das ein riesen Vorteil von PowerShell ist.
Einer, wo ich wirklich sagen würde, das ist ein Vorteil von PowerShell,
weil PowerShell eben kein Text zwischen den Kommandos hin und her pipet,
sondern PowerShell-Objekte hin und her pipet.
Da hast du wahrscheinlich genau, DayMutv.
Ich denke, in dem Fall hast du tatsächlich mit PowerShell wenig Probleme.
Da kriegst du einfach ein File-System-Object irgendwie rüber gepasst,
wo alles schon richtig auch schön escaped ist, wenn du es dann so ums Dreh rum wandelst.
Mit PowerShell hast du wahrscheinlich keine Probleme in dem Fall.
Was jetzt? Ah, okay. Big-Prain-Play.
Installieren einfach PowerShell unter Linux.
Und dann machen wir es damit.
Aber können wir mittlerweile.
Weil das ist alles mittlerweile.NET Core und da läuft PowerShell auch ganz gut.
Das wäre mal hier. Next Level.
Ja, Leute. Ich muss jetzt was essen.
Ähm.
Haben wir sogar noch ein bisschen Technik-Kram am Ende gemacht,
der nicht so geplant war.
Aber das finde ich interessant mit dem hier, mit dieser Geschichte mit escapem.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt.
Okay, das macht er richtig.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt hier Dateien anlege mit einem Double-Quad drin,
dann spackt er hier wahrscheinlich.
Ähm. Zurecht. Zurecht spackt er dann hier drinnen.
Und hier kann er.
Ja, das ist echt fies. Das ist wirklich.
Das ist wirklich fies, ja.
Das ist ein Problem. Das hatte ich in der Form noch nicht.
Was sagt man das?
Das hatte ich in dem Fall so ein Problem.
Aber das ist wirklich ein interessantes.
Interessantes Problem.
Eigentlich, was man möchte, ist, dass das Feind.
X-Arcs. Ja, das.
Das ist das, was ich am Anfang auch gesagt habe.
Man könnte einfach X-Arcs nehmen, wobei ich mir gar nicht mal sicher bin,
ob man mit X-Arcs in diesem Fall weniger Probleme hat.
Weil das ist ja kein Problem.
Das ist eigentlich kein Problem von Feind.
Sondern ein Problem von.
Dass der hier rumspackt, wenn ich das Double-Quadte,
wenn die Pfeilnamen Double-Quads.
Wir können das mal mit X-Arcs ausprobieren.
Ich sag's, war es auch geschweifte Klammer.
Wie ging das?
Moment, findet ihr überhaupt was?
Perfect, mach's gut.
Aber wenn ich einfach nur X-Arcs mache.
Was? Unmatched?
Genau, der mag nicht, weil da Quads drin sind.
Das ist ein Quads.
Aber was wir machen könnten ist.
Minus 0 ist doch eigentlich nur Line-Ending, ne?
Oder macht er das? Excapt er den bis dann auch?
Input Items, genau.
Ah.
Quads and Backslash are not special.
Das ist natürlich schon mal praktisch.
Dann habe ich am Anfang mit X-Arcs doch gar nicht mal...
...wo verkehrt.
Ach fuck, ey.
Dann muss ich mal den Karo...
Konnte man den Mist nicht irgendwie quäuten? Doch, geht doch.
Aber mit X-Arcs müsste es doch wirklich dann funktionieren.
Ist nicht bei...
Ah.
Wenn ich sage, kein Schimmer.
Ja gut, es ist wieder das Gleiche, das wir jetzt sagen müssen.
Bash minus C.
Was auch immer.
Ich gehe jetzt was futtern.
Aber das ist wirklich ein interessantes Problem.
Das hatte ich noch nicht.
Ich meine, man hat normalerweise auch keine Quads in der Teilnahme.
Na die Pipes...
Naja, gut.
Wenn du die Pipes hinter das X-Arcs-Zeugs machst...
...dann würdest du ja den kompletten...
...den kompletten Output...
...den kompletten Output von X-Arcs...
...Char 512 und das ist ja nicht, was der Mau will.
Der Mau möchte ja jeden einzelnen Eintrag quasi...
...Char 512.
Aber...
Jo, immer.
Er macht das jetzt eh...
...mit einer Poker-Miersprache, wo das nicht so eklig ist, die Sachen zu eskäppen.
Aber das Problem hatte ich echt noch nicht.
Das ist ein interessantes Problem.
Die Teilnahme mit Quads und...
Single- und Double-Quads.
Warum hat man überhaupt eine Teilnahme mit Single- und Double-Quads?
Ich meine, nicht, dass es trotzdem...
...sollte man eine Möglichkeit finden, wie man das machen kann.
Aber Teilnahmen mit Single- und Double-Quads sind schon relativ selten, oder?
Also ich hab da...
Ich sag mal so, ich sehe selten welche.
Vielleicht, wenn es irgendein Meldier ist oder sowas...
...und Leute ihre Sachen mit Quads drinnen benennen.
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall mal ein...
...interessantes Problem gewesen.
Max, hast du einen Full-HD-Monitor oder WQHD?
Nein, ich hab einen Full-HD. Ich hab zwei Full-HD-Monitore nebeneinander.
Also quasi...
...quasi widescreen Full-HD.
Warum kein WQHD?
Weil ich die Monitore schon ne ganze Weile hab.
Da war WQHD noch nicht so angesagt.
Okay Leute, ich geh was futtern.
Mach Schluss.
Wenn du übelst lange am Start...
...meine Verhältnisse...
Ähm...
Schauen wir mal, ob wir irgendeinen haben, den wir hosten können.
Tim, du kannst doch einfach alle Dateien umbenennen.
Das stimmt wohl.
Aber wahrscheinlich hat es schon einen Grund, warum die so heißen.
Ähm...
Was ist das denn?
Devcom.
Official Event Stream. Was wird da gedeft?
Gamescom Developer Event.
Grills.
Ähm...
Was ist das denn?
Ach, das ist diese Geschichte, wo manche...
Ach, doch das...
Klar, da hab ich auch schon ein paar Webcasts von gesehen.
Wo sie dann Entwickler haben, die halt...
...Dinger erzählen oder über Microtransactions...
...erzählen oder sowas.
War hier was auf Deutsch?
Was ist denn, Ajax?
Own Network System for...
Ach so.
ASP.According Content Management.
Wir programmieren ein wenig. Was programmiert er denn?
The Shy Guy.
Tür offene? Was?
Was ist das für eine Sprache?
Was ist das für eine Sprache und was ist das für eine...
...für eine IDE? Was hat er da?
Was ist das?
Ist das irgendein JavaScript?
Nee, oder?
Es hat ein bisschen was von C Sharp, aber es sieht überhaupt nicht aus wie...
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Arduino?
Äh...
Java? Kann das Java sein?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Es ist Java.
Java.
Den kann man nicht hosten.
Schaut mal, ob irgendwer anderes online ist, den ich hosten kann von denen, den ich...
...followe.
Der letzte sah noch gut aus.
Welcher?
LegendaryBotDev?
Den versteht man nicht.
LegendaryBot.
Ist irgendwie heute nichts dabei. Programme mal kurz für alle, denen ich followe, ob da...
...irgendjemand dabei ist, den man hosten könnte. Ein bisschen von den kleineren.
Also noch kleiner als ich.
Nope.
Nee, okay, keine Ahnung, Leute, ich geh jetzt was essen.
Nachdem...
Nachdem die Leute gestern ja schon mein Outro, meine Outro-Musik vermisst haben, muss ich...
...mach mal wieder Outro-Musik an.
Also Leute, macht's gut, bis denn. See you.
Gute Nacht, Leute.
Gute Nacht.
Wohin gehst du, wohin gehst du?